[Music]
foreign
not in these positions within the
Tempest the best have come to test their
skills and brave the storm that is down
to five seconds
oh we missed it
for some this is familiar ground I've
never seen Magnus Player move like that
one second
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97.
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
send your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
foreign
welcome everybody to the 2022 speed
chess championships I am International
Master David pruce and I am joined by
noted streamer gmjx
welcome Jeffrey how are you today
thank you good morning David uh it's
super early for both of us but I do have
faith that uh as as we move along we
will uh get more and more energized
start waking up so it's a pleasure to be
here with you
yeah and uh Jeffrey you also happen to
be a super Grand Master and you've
played in several of these uh speed
chess championships yourself how many
matches have you played
well it's a very good question
um yeah I have made it maybe two times
unfortunately never passed the first
round uh I'm not that good so yeah just
two I I lost mvl and I think I lost to
Wesley last year okay well we will be
watching the first round today so it'll
be territory that you know well
um here is our bracket and uh we have
one match in the books and uh seven more
to go in this first round
um what what do you see in this bracket
here what stands out to you
yeah I believe it was four days ago we
saw a a thriller between uh Fabian
arjunior guys see Fabi just edging out
Arjun there and today ding versus
grishek I also expect a very tight match
um definitely with lean ding but we'll
see what what does uh
what the smarter chess think about this
are you going to tend to agree or
disagree with smarter chess once you
almost I mean I almost always disagree
with him okay but let's let's find out
if that Trend continues let's find out
because I would also lean towards Ding
and smarter chess does as well
yeah this this looks quite accurate uh
surprisingly enough
I would I'm not sure that Ding is uh
favored this much in five minutes I
think Grisha can definitely battle him
there I'd say I'd give ding like a one
point Edge in five and three minute and
then and boy it's probably a toss-up
because
initially I thought okay ding his bullet
would be his weakness but last year I I
saw him go Toe to Toe with with a car
there who we know is is a bullet Beast
yeah
that's right
um so I I mean in general Chinese
players don't play a lot of bullet
because of the internet connection in
China not being as fast as just not as
fun to play 1-0 I think
um so ding doesn't have a lot of
practice with it but you throw on the
one second increment and you saw him in
last year's uh semi-finals going
absolutely low for blow Toe to Toe with
the color Nakamura who's obviously known
as the best bullet player in the world
so
um so he should be able to keep up in
that format if the match is this close
in five minute and three minute like if
it's a one point game then of course you
get to the bullet and even if one player
is favored it feels like pretty close to
uh toss-up right
yeah and absolutely I think you
mentioned two very important points
first of all the one second increment
super beneficial to ding
but also the connection like sometimes
we've seen Dean lose his Connection in
these online events so hopefully uh it
maintains for him today but yeah in
general I look forward to a very very
close exciting match
all right
so
um the match is starting very very
shortly
um we're gonna quickly tell everybody
the format for those of you who aren't
familiar with the speed Chess
Championship some of you are you know
you can nod along or nodders along
um it is a 16 player knockout at this
point some players had to qualify in but
we have 16 players now
each match has three time controls uh
five minute chest three minute chest and
one minute chest as we just saw and uh
in each time control you play until time
runs out and then the game that you're
currently playing needs to finish so if
you've got um a game currently going in
the three minute section and the score
is seven to seven and time runs out that
last game you will play it out to the
end and it will count towards the score
yep well said
and I do believe Games should be
underway shortly then make sure I'm
following players
all right
um and as we saw for a second folks if
the match finishes in an out and out tie
after all three time controls are done
we have two different uh tie breaks
ready one is a four game mini match of
one minute chess
um and if that finishes two two then we
have an Armageddon uh game with bidding
but here are the players and let's get
into the action any openings you're
hoping to see today Jeffrey anything you
you love
yeah I think the opening battle will be
crucial
um
ding probably I'll I think we'll see C4
mostly or some Nims or Catalan and the
most interesting for me is when grishek
has white because he plays both E4 and
D4 so I'm not sure if he'll challenge uh
being super solid e45 Reptar or will he
also battle uh things nimsa we'll see
mm-hmm
all right so we are underway here
Queen's Gambit declined to start both
players still blitzing
and now what C5 for black
yeah C5 is a move Bishop B4 check was
also
um this is I think this is quite
theoretical if I remember well
um so yeah I'm curious to see what both
players have prepared did they
delve very deeply or are they just gonna
stick to their usual weapons
right B3 challenging black on the side
of the board where black has made a big
effort to quickly become strong pushing
both the C pawn and the b-pawn up
grabbing a lot of space
um
if black doesn't push the C Pawn up
sometimes white plays for pressure on
the C file but um here black looks
pretty strong on the queen side
and uh
what what do you think of this tension
on C4 it looks to me like black should
be strong there yeah I'm worried a
little bit about A4 because A4 would be
extremely hard to meet you'd want to
meet that with A6 but the Rook on 8 is
hanging in that line also important to
point out C3 is not a move due to Queen
D3 with the double attack even triple
yeah triple attack on B5 C3 and H7 so I
guess
this should be seven here just so that
you can you have this A6 move on on A4
right
yeah that's what I'm expecting as well
Bishop B7
um
sometimes in these structures white
tries to play E4 so the bishop is not oh
but I realized something I'm sorry
Bishop B7 there could be like a BC yeah
and queen B1 exactly otherwise he
wouldn't think a minute and a half on
this move
right so how do you solve the problem
like if you play Knight F6 or Knight B6
I'm slightly worried about A4 although
play A6 first here perhaps
and if A4 and if a410 Bishop B7 but I
still think I would have the same idea
right with with Queen B1 it was A5 wow
wow
so he was prepared to answer A4 with B4
perhaps and then yeah and just try and
queen the pawns real quick
so ding open this B file quickly I guess
he wants to use the fact that his Bishop
controls B8 so it's harder for black to
to contest it right and when white took
on C4 black might have liked to play DC
to go with the a pawn and play B4 and
Bishop B7 have an open diagonal but
there would have been Queen B1 again so
you so that's why ding took immediately
then because he knew it was forcing B
take C and it feels almost like ding is
in his opening prep still
he's already built a two-minute
advantage on the clock we know how
methodical grishek is though and how
good he plays with with seconds on the
clock though
yeah definitely not unusual to see
grishock use all his time
yeah Rook B1
however I think it's going to be hard
for him to get the other rook in so
I mean to me the issue is white just
playing E4 somewhere around here and the
black minor pieces not being super well
organized
definitely an idea
I'm not sure you play it right away I
want to fight on the the beefel and play
Move Like A3 but I guess Bishop wants to
take on B1 takes Bishop A3 right and uh
maybe the A3 Pawn is hanging in some
lines
yeah
so now what other ideas are there beside
E4 because E4 I'm worried that black
will take it and go Knight F6
yeah
and then
if the queen tries to find room to
bother black at C6 black seems to have
Bishop B7 and and uh have all the
squares covered
hmm looks like a critical moment for
ding I must say
yeah he thinks so as well
as he takes his first real think of the
match
it's funny he'd actually love to be able
to take that Bishop that he got outside
the pawn chain and played Bishop D2 here
that would be yes a really good move if
you could pressure that ape Pawn
yeah I think this lesson was was quite
strong by grishek now I'm thinking of
something a bit funky with Queen D1 with
the idea of A3 and recapturing with the
queen I was just thinking of A3 and
recapturing with the bishop
followed by Queen C2 and then Knight F6
you know white can play Bishop E5 or 95.
yeah so lots of possibilities here he's
still taking his time
now moves I would never consider are
Rook takes B4 okay
all right now let's see if he wants to
sack on A3 or he's gonna go with your
idea
wow he's second guessing on the
recapture after all that yeah that's not
a great site or it does sack him maybe
does he want Rook B5 or
what is his idea on Bishop takes
I do not know
Maybe
okay
but are you really getting to my D5 Pawn
I've got negative six Bishop B6
um also like Knight F6 let's say you try
to pin me with Bishop G5 right I think I
can just go Bishop B7 there and hold
hold everything together for the moment
yeah
also would you consider just sacrificing
the a pawn like Bishop E6 Bishop F6
Queen F6
may I mean black should be fine there I
think basically black has a position
where they could lose one pawn and still
be fine but if I'd love to keep that a
pawn and sort of beat white by surprise
with it I don't know how big a surprise
it would be but
it looks like quite a good Pawn for
trying to win the game let's say
yeah he is content with giving it up
because after Bishop 6 you don't want to
take with the G Pawn in uh weaken your
king too much about Knight H4 Queen H5
right
okay 95 played we won't even see for
sure which way he would recapture since
ding builds the tension now Knight C6 is
a huge threat because you've always got
these Bishop F6 Queen H5 stuff
Place rookie eight ah so he's gonna make
room for the king I believe making room
for the king also for Bishop f8
so just to show this line because it's
very important Knight C6 Queen D7 Bishop
F6 Queen C6 there's no longer a queen H5
because you freed the square for the
king so now you can go GF and run with
the King via E7
yeah uh but we might see this so Knight
C6
after Queen D7 the pieces would both be
hanging so he would have been sort of
tied
tied up all right
now here Rook A5 is possible because of
the bishop position yeah this feels very
risky though
not sure
they should be for what's he planning
oh Bishop B4 would have been a crazy
move there but it simplifies this
Rook A6 there would have been Rook Ace
yeah yeah white did have some options
there but this is I guess this is a very
safe approach maybe grishek had more
but
I don't think he should ever lose this
position either
yeah I mean he needs to take care of
back Rank and do something with the Rook
that can't go to B8
offering a trade of Rooks very logical
yeah does everything he needs
so at some point I'm expecting bishop4 I
think you just get rid of this Knight oh
he's gonna be ambitious here with F3
yeah I thought he would go after three
four because if you just take on e4
then basically you need to come defend
the C3 square with that bishop and just
huddle down and play for a draw right I
was thinking take on e4 Queen B2 make a
draw but ding has other plans
oh yeah because of the back rank you're
just gonna Force Queen B8 huh yes okay
now actually but you know what's weird
or something yeah if black had played H6
in that line of yours I don't think you
can go Queen B8 because C3 would Queen
deployment right that other line that
we're looking at yeah
so this F3 with the possibility of Z4
and G4 I think it keeps more
tension for white and that Bishop on C2
is blockading
the C Pawn for the moment so I wouldn't
be in a rush to trade it off yeah I have
to say the more I look at this the more
I like these chances because it's hard
for black to stop uh E4 from coming in
I'm noticing 20 seconds on grishok's
clock but you don't think that's a big
issue here do you
no it might be
this position could start sharpening up
well here it comes if black takes then
there's a crazy past D Pawn for white
that can get going quickly right you
absolutely cannot allow that
so grashook allows the space gain
instead
and the space game with e45 is scarier
with more pieces on the board so here
it's sort of okay right I'm
I assume he keeps the tension for now
just keep uh he'll keep B5 in his back
pocket but for now maybe you play a move
like Bishop G3 something flexible
okay
so control of the F5 square is vital
yeah
I completely misguessed
hunger shook was going to play this I
thought the Knight was headed towards
the queen side for counter play with the
c Pawn
instead it's over here on the king side
yeah Bishop F5 and I think
ah now maybe there's Bishop B4 actually
can white still push here
G4 key G3
yep wait a second not good yet these
pawns are starting to go up the board
at some point Bishop C6 will just win
the center Pawn well Knight F4 uh he's
ready ah you've got H4 Bishop seven
oh man and only three seconds for
Griffin he didn't trade yeah that's a
shocking decision but I mean he's
thinking that you know Black's gonna be
tied to that H6 Square
right it's still good
nice
um
wow Richard playing on seconds yeah two
seconds for him
opens up another weakness
you've got to go before at some
point Bishops right now that you've got
that square free up the night no Bishop
d8 okay
you still got before yeah he finds
it yeah
I think he's holding
he does seem to be holding yeah I think
you can just play kh7 G7
and then wow
very tense game one um maybe a bit of
nurse for both players I think both
sides had chance at some point but draw
a fair result
yeah I feel in that pure end game the
risks were definitely all in uh
gershuk's Camp so he can be happy that
that nothing happened
certainly yeah
now we get an anti-kataline here let's
see which one okay so ding allows a
benoni with reverse colors
yeah
don't see this super often
um in fact people have asked me
my channel why don't you see this benoni
with reverse colors very much at uh GM
levels I had that question before it's
like even with an extra Tempo not a lot
of GM's like this uh structure
right yeah because I'm not sure if the
extra shampoo helps you so much uh from
White's point of view but this is an
interesting approach from Grisham he's
just
uh pushing up all these pawns on the
queen side
the black takes he'll happily exchange
it for the center Pawn
yeah and the bishop G2 will wake up
indeed
okay Bishop five
looking at D3 and C2 and B1 now
right lines it all up for that Bishop
now the move I want to play is E4 but I
don't think it works
on account of native
the unite fd4 although
yeah although there is a bishop G4 there
so it could be interesting
once you play Bishop G4 the queen can
just move and you don't have much oomph
on that
F5 B1 diagonal
mm-hmm
yeah I guess it doesn't quite work
but otherwise black needs to do
something because C5 and B5 are on tap
yeah
E4 Knight D4 takes takes and this is
there no trick there oh so e494 takes
takes
maybe bishop takes B4 there whoa Knight
F5
so we're looking at this
Queen E1 ed3 I guess white has enough
control of the position that yeah that
it doesn't quite work
but there are I mean these these lines
do exist like maybe
I'm still trying to make this bishop G4
move work
um but you're saying here for white too
yeah well I was
so it doesn't seem to be quite working
grishek's still or uh excuse me ding
rather still thinking here
you can play a move like H6 Bishop H7 if
you think white doesn't have uh serious
threats yeah if you don't think B5 does
much yet
we've got the opposite clock situation
from game one
um or or the same situation depending on
whether you look at the colors of the
players but um you're shook playing is
opening very confidently with white this
time and ding using a lot of time
yeah lightning fast he's only used five
seconds
okay Rook C8 so the good thing is if C5
black will get this juicy D5 score for
the Knight yep
I could even maybe play Knight D5
without retreating the bishop
very true yeah because you know cd6
Knight C3 and you have to play Queen D2
and give your Rook with Tempo your queen
has so little in his face exactly yeah
that's a nice tactic but here I'm
worried about Bishop G5 that's why I
liked H6 a bit better to stop that
yeah you know Bishop G5 doesn't go the
best with the Knight 82 plan but when
you ask like what is black or white get
out of the extra Tempo in the benoni one
option is basically there wasn't time
for the other player to play H6 in the
first you know seven moves and so you
can get like one Bishop trade but that
normally goes with like a knight D2
Knight E4 plan not Knight A3 to C2
yeah this is what I want I want to go
Bishop G5 and A2 Knight E4 but D3 is
hanging um as you point out maybe bishop
G5 and Knight H4 could be
could be the new idea
um I guess he's also calculating B5 here
something like ABAB Knight A5
not sure if that benefits White
so yeah Rook CA give him a lot to think
about too
when you're black in these positions
sometimes you play Knight H4 Bishop G4
Bishop F3 and you just go back and forth
trying to get it you know offering that
trade
but as white I'm not sure it has white
it doesn't make any sense I still like
Bishop G5 and Knight H4
um
this is what I would play
but once you play Bishop G5
black will play H6 and then tuck the
bishop on H7
um
yeah so the reason why I want to kill
this Knight is because
I'm trying to play the C5 idea without
allowing Knight D5 that's my my main
point
gotcha
so you would give you would trade off
the one Bishop sit tonight on H4 play C5
yeah see he played it after two minutes
31 seconds I wanted to play it after 30
seconds two seconds and 30 milliseconds
yeah
well aside from the moves we expect
uh-huh
so
yeah again I really want to play 9294 I
was even considering playing Rook B3 but
okay it does go Knight H4 probably
Bishop H7 I'm guessing
no it goes the other way
interesting now I'd be looking for some
pushes over here
he's got to do something about the
Knight on C2
yeah typical ID is also B5 and Knight B4
right
so B5 is going to force the Knight to
either A5 or d8 to
protect the pond okay we get a totally
different approach
yeah I'm not sure what this does exactly
I'm worried that now
you have to move like B6 maybe 97 will
come with tempo
yeah this move I would associate with
the follow-up like Queen F3 that doesn't
look especially good
yeah or like a a Rover if you could but
that's clearly not possible
Queen F3
is a move I don't know how you would
evaluate your chances in that end game
yeah
oh by the way there is a positional Pawn
SEC idea here you go C5 BC and B5
and the idea to get a pass Pond there
and the C4 square but he does offer the
The Exchange
yeah
my guess would be that black has to be
okay in the end game
should be yeah
because you don't really have a clear
weakness like E5 is quite well protected
maybe you can take in like king f8
um just play simply
yeah
all right he's thinking what other moves
are there
like Bishop E7 but that doesn't look
right
once we get into the end game I can even
see black playing A5
fighting for those dark squares fighting
for the dark squares and trying to keep
the knights stuck on C2 right by getting
control of A3 and B4
because to me yeah definitely a problem
you're right you're absolutely right
this is the the worst piece on the board
um
now grishek
for grishek I think you first
repositioned this Knight like I'm
looking for all kinds of Pawn bricks on
the queen side
but I think you want to
reroute this Knight first
192 to E4 with a tempo
now it's a bullet game and you know
they're they're pretty early in the game
to be down to a minute each this one
yeah this could be a preview for what
we're about what we're gonna see in
OnePlus One
um
I think it should be balanced because
both sides are maintaining control of T
squares not many weaknesses for either
side 97. he's offering the pawn I guess
he can win a piece almost oh no The Rook
I see but how like you take F6 and maybe
wait don't I have Bishop E6 there I
think Dean blundered this
I've got 95 Bishop B5 I'll show it
rookie five F6 and Bishop V6 is very
important here
uh but 14 seconds for grishek
let's see if he he sees that or not
it could also go 95. he sees it yeah he
found it
and now Bishop V6 oh he sacks okay this
is also good
yeah but I think 56 would have uh I mean
he could have held on to The Exchange
there
uh let's see what he does here five
seconds
very important that the bishop is
controlling on A8
yeah things got the last big think of
the game King C5 is what I wanted to do
okay Knight C2 do you go Bishop F5 I
really like my prospects too uh-huh and
if I check in 93
who knows at least one rep got active
maybe maybe Rook D2 yeah is a good move
yes
very good move two seconds
oh there's a fork here on C4 but black
is better in that position well he Flags
oh my goodness oh my goodness bullet
preview he didn't know how critical it
was that might have been lagged it might
have been lag I'm not sure or or some
nerves but in any case not a great game
to drop he was still fine in that
position
but yeah we'll see I would have had
black would have had like a small Edge
if he went Knight C4 huh but like it's I
think so yeah yeah but it's still
holding could you block with the Knight
you have a past b-pawn
um
yeah he's exciting very very tender
isolated pawns here
yeah completely symmetrical position
see if they keep copying each other
Knight of five no okay
I just counted real quick nothing was
hanging
yeah I like this for grishek though
looks solid you go Knight F5 you just
yeah
your opponent's showing you all your
moves it's very convenient in a Blitz
game
right I'm always so annoyed when I'm
playing with white and my opponent
copies me because it feels like
the onus is on on me to to figure out
how to deviate but then if you do
it might not be in your favor
right
also if black plays Knight F5 I mean not
just could they trade on E3 and make
everything symmetrical cool again but
the d-pawn would be
almost dead I mean we'd be playing 92
for white
yeah which is certainly not what you
want so yeah I agree with you D4 is
quite soft Bishop G2 is being blunted
for now I imagine that the bishop goes
on H3 in the future to at least Target
this this guy but if we went to H3 with
the bishop and then the Knight came to
F5 and we traded that night that
position would be wretched right
exactly yeah because White's pawns would
all be on the same color as its Bishop
um so yeah positionally black would
would have the upper hand there maybe G4
here wow not fast enough
I would not have considered that it
looks weakening but I do understand
at all costs yes
yeah and what I want to do next is going
to seem horrifying to you as well
I want to play H4 H5 next run here you
have the board I mean I can I can
respect that I would also go F4 just to
make sure there are no E5 ideas for
black
yeah why would what I would probably do
is play something like Queen D2 Rook 81
first like coordinate my heavy pieces a
little bit
but but my long-term plan is the H5 Pawn
break
you know actually E5 immediately might
be a move
what do you make of this line like E5 D5
D4
and if you go Queen B3 check th8 I'm
thinking now G4 is hanging
so I don't know I guess there is a pin
so I'm not threatening either of your
pieces
maybe you can play like F4
um
but yeah this could be just one of these
things
or rook d8 and then I am
uh so you mean losing my piece oh
because yeah now I protect the queen
yeah
aha yeah and now unfortunately I'm
forced to sack F4 was very ambitious
yeah I guess maybe something else like
like a 94
um and it probably wouldn't have been
working
right he went for more conservative move
Knight C8
yeah I think I think Knight B5 might be
the move putting the most pressure on D4
and then but okay he's maneuvering
elsewhere with this Knight B3 to keep it
out of C4 so we see
we see dang in full like restriction
mode on these nights right the first
thing to do sometimes with the bishop
pair is deprive the enemies Knights of
central outposts
yes indeed
um I'm expecting F4 at some point
I don't know when
because you you do have like 92 to
to bolster it
would be nice if that Knight on C3 were
somewhere else
yeah maybe you will I think he will play
92 very uh very soon
um I'm looking at Knight A4 as well but
I'm worried that black will do this oh
now I could do it yeah because I was
worried about B6
but here
I guess grishek wants to to play Knight
B5
oh wow just going after D4
now white has the move Rook D2 to defend
it as just sort of an extra
option
I kept thinking the queen would be on D2
to play Rook D1 but with the way he's
playing
I'll have Rook D2 as an extra understand
there we see this F4 move
and grishek is trying to organize
pressure on D4 I feel maybe some Queen
B6 and later Knight B5
but uh You Gotta Be You Gotta watch out
for this F5 move lurking in some
positions
yeah because of the D5 Pawn uh
that may be tactically possible for
white in some cases
exactly also just Knight takes D5 is
something to keep an eye on throughout
yeah where you get a rook and two pawns
for the pieces I wouldn't be sure how to
to estimate that yeah
I'm not sure it means you know it's
close enough for us to keep an eye on it
close enough for grishek to sidestep
here and avoid any nonsense with that
and for ding it's hard to form a plan
because if not F5
what other what other breaks well this
Knight needs to be somewhere else if he
wants to to do something like you a good
plan would be just dropping that Knight
on E5 that would
ah you mean like th1 Knight G1 Knight F3
yeah
but yeah it's you're gonna have to stay
tied to this point wait this move now
allows h4h5 though this is the one plan
that you mentioned at the beginning that
I quite like because
black is without its light squared
Bishop so these pawns are going to be
harder to protect
yeah
but now there's also like Knight B5
right like okay he he backs off after
thinking a moment but that was you know
the big moment to attack D4 with
everybody
yeah I think ding had Rook D1 there
um in that case
but Grisha clearly wary of the h4h5 so
he's uh keeping an eye on the square
so King H1
Bishop F3
does he want to just slowly try and
prepare H4
right or is he gonna play H4 and Sack
the pawn
ah yes yeah he might start with like a
queen D3 move exactly so he's ready to
take G6 by surprise as well
but
the more that I think about it wait
maybe H4 is a threat because after Queen
H4 you go G5 closing the queen and you
threaten to trap it on the next move
maybe 94 here is a good move for black
offering this exchange hmm yeah just
decimating our own Pawn structure but
like the white king is always going to
be vulnerable as the game opens up and
how does white take the E Pawn without
allowing you know some kind of counter
on D4 I'd probably go Rook D1 there and
I'd have Knights who threw a Queen City
next
you over protect D4 preparing to do that
but like black plays Rook D7 let's say
uh okay yeah he's gonna hold off on that
idea now H4 is is possible
yeah
the queen D3 looks quite good also Queen
D3 yeah stopping Knight E4 and preparing
I like windy three a lot yeah
okay oh but grishek's waiting that is
not a good sign
because you think ultimately white can
continue improving
well it's usually never a good sign when
you show like you're willing to go back
and forth and wait to see how the other
side makes progress
um will we play no he's gonna he's gonna
just agree to withdraw okay oh man
uh we are left with some questions about
how that position can play out right
yeah I wanted to I wanted to play Queen
B1 there and still go with my my H4
ideas with H4 yeah
but wonders but all right you get you
get your first to see E4
yeah first before game we'll probably
see a marshall
this looks like a match strategy from
grishuk like he planned to test
both E4 well both uh I guess C4 and E4
early on and uh
see what what things playing today
yeah I think that's what you have to do
against a player like ding you're not
gonna just be able to refute one of his
openings so jumping around is probably
the the way to go
when I played in the I am not an SCC
match I would go into the match with
some kind of plan like that Jeffrey like
I'd be like okay first I want to like
try this opening then I want to try that
I want to test it there and then once
you're playing the game
I am so caught up in it I just forget
any match strategy that I had and just
just keep like fighting you know move by
move yeah did you like did you prepare a
lot before matches or mainly just going
with the flow oh you did okay
yeah because
um because I you know I don't have too
much else going on in my life so if I've
got a match it's rare enough that I'll
prepare for it
and the other the other players like
punching you in the face and like I
don't know do you do you think it's
normal to keep track of your your Match
Prep in a blitz situation it's so hard
like I also spent I did my due diligence
before every jscc match every SEC I'd
prepare like five different openings for
both colors but I noticed that the
moment the match starts I forget
everything I prepared so okay it's
normally better just to be in good Blitz
shape I think uh-huh yeah so that's what
I'm noticing here with like uh your
shook is he didn't forget that that's
what was standing out to me having
forgotten every time I'm seeing this guy
did not forget
okay this is an interesting
transformation here is gonna play
with the iqp
right with some C file weaknesses for
black
yeah C6 is also a bit loose I wondering
what he wants after Bishop G4 though
maybe Queen C2
oh wow Queen C2 there
yeah
if Bishop F3 Queen C6 and blacks bishop
and Knight look awkward to me
yeah that line works just to show it um
because actually I can't move my knight
either due to Bishop D5
this is a cheeky idea by you
yeah
and if you give way give ground with the
Knight then Knight E5 is of course
amazing but um
maybe I'd go like Queen D7 there
yeah I think the key line would be
Bishop G4 Queen C2 Queen D7 mm-hmm
he's gonna go
there should be six try and solidify on
D5 right so against
against Bishop E6 or Bishop B7 I think
you know Knight D2 to E4 to C5 would
have been
a major plan for Kershaw but um I've got
a question not just for you Jeffrey I
know you're a sports fan but also for
all of chat
um which of these two players do you
think would be a better football player
so I know that Ding plays a lot of
basketball he also plays football I
remember one of the y-con days there was
a video where uh he played with Magnus
and all the grand Masters there on the
rest day so I'd have to go with ding
based on that knowledge
okay
and do you ever play uh football
yourself
uh you mean European football right
European or International Football yeah
International Football I played as a kid
when I was five or six back in Columbus
Ohio but uh in a little while that's
it's been a while yeah
probably I would say
since
I mean when they got rid of recess like
in Middle School I stopped playing in
fifth grade I was still playing
why did they get rid of Reese I don't
know I don't know I wonder that I wonder
that to this day yeah jeez
brutal wow pushing pushing pushing
if Bishop D3 I guess he would have kept
chasing that piece with Knight before
um
so ding's got some Queen side space and
looking for counter play
when you've got space it's always a
question right you have weaknesses or do
you have counter play
exactly and here
I probably favor White's chances to
attack black doesn't have too many
pieces
uh guarding the king Knight eg5 is very
scary also Queen D3 lining up the
battery
right
from that perspective night before it's
a little bit scary because it takes that
piece even further away from the King
yeah the movie you want to go is H6 but
then after Queen D3 you would no longer
have G6
and you don't even have Knight before
you don't have night before due to this
beautiful mate I'll just show it
whoops
opening the queen
so maybe maybe rookie eight here is the
most
but wow 40 seconds for dig
yeah I mean he he's gotta spend some
time figuring out how not to get made
it's not so easy
goes Bishop F5 so this allows Knight F6
winning the bishop pair
yeah and I also just like to move 95.
just waiting a moment and like you know
when when the night's on A5 you come to
E5 then it's
stuck on the side and black doesn't want
to play the move F6 too much in this
position with light squared Bishop
likely coming off the board
yeah I agree with you 95 can't be bad
you'd also maybe threaten Bishop D2
there
um yeah and maybe even Queen H5
or queen F3 yeah lots of good ideas to
choose from I think Knight F6 is the
safe way because when you win this
bishop pair you know that you're better
so yeah we'll see which one he goes for
I agree it's promising
yeah and dig really low on time so this
could be a chance for Sasha to score his
first full point of
the match always important to get that
first win on the board
oh yeah it is I remember one of my
matches
it took so long and I was starting to
get worried that I might not get a win
until the bullet section
right yeah you don't want to be you
don't want to be second guessing that
like am I gonna get a full point
yeah luckily I never had to play some
like Hikaru Magnus so I didn't worry I
didn't have to worry about adoption
right
so yeah he does take the bishop away
he must be planning to just sack a Pawn
on C2
ah yes this is a good idea you're
pointing out because then you would get
the B3 Square you might not even be
sacking anything
right
okay if you're gonna try and go after D4
and B2 pretty quickly
um you can also play Queen D5 first it's
not like we have to just straight up
plunk the Knight on C2 but I think
that's the main idea
here
yeah I tend to agree with that so maybe
go Bishop D2
um
so okay I guess if Knight C2 he's gonna
take twice and say that c7's hanging in
this line yeah but G6 is a good good
tempo
now what
I don't see anything impressive with
Knight C4 Queen B3
yeah I'm trying to calculate some ideas
none of them seem to work though
and meanwhile Rook C1 is
is simply
the next move for white
or even
Queen D2
but then maybe night sequence yeah I
don't really want to allow 94 so Rook C1
makes more sense
and now can you go Rook C5
rishik is very very close here
yeah Brooks C5 is a great idea
that really puts black on the edge
guess there still might be seven in that
line
oh I like this move too opening up in
front yes
okay 28 he's giving up C7 though
but he's threatening E4 so but B8 would
be hanging that line Bishop C7 rookie
for rookie 4.84 Bishop p8 okay
I think Bishop C7 just wins material
unless I'm crazy yeah he does play it
exit yeah
that's that time advantage that you know
you can stop now and then and double
check something risky your opponent does
and he had yeah
he had nothing to do there and that ties
up the match two to two and it's gonna
bring us to our first break we are
halfway through the opening five and one
time control
um there's gonna be a very short break
and uh then we will be back everybody
with another 45 minutes of Blitz chess
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing which
has a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to the speed Chess Championship here you
see 39 year old super Grand Master
Alexander grishek he
um has fought his way into the speed
Chess Championship bracket through the
qualification system this year
he's got his ratings up in the
stratospheres still
um they sometimes say Blitz is a game
for teenagers Jeffrey I don't know if
you're already starting to feel like
shoot I'm a couple years older than some
of these guys but but he's got his Blitz
ratings right around the 3100 mark
and
um he has made it to the semi-finals
once in the sphs Championships
Yeah you mentioned teenager I still feel
like grishek is a teenager at heart he
plays with such tremendous energy uh
every time he gets himself uh
on the board so this uh SEC qualifier by
the way was such a grueling process I
played in both the first and second
um you ought to be sharp just to qualify
for that knockout and uh for him I mean
he went through a gauntlet of players um
he was playing past midnight uh for his
local time so just super impressive
stuff and it's great to see him here
yeah and uh people in the chat also
mentioning Sasha is famous for his Thug
Life uh approach to uh to interviews and
to talking about the Chess World he is
one of the most entertaining players to
uh to talk to in the whole Chess World
um and uh yeah he fought that whole
Gauntlet now he's got a shot at the
number two player in the world
for sure yeah I always love my Sasha
interviews I
certainly get a good laugh uh every time
he gives one so yeah we'll see if we can
hear some more uh today yeah so another
little tidbit about Sasha is that he is
the three-time world Blitz Champion
um he won it in 2006 2012 and 2015. and
no that's not big in my ear that's
that's research
yeah that's amazing uh do you think he
has the most worthless titles because
three is a lot it is a it is a lot you
know it's the the world Blitz title is
not like a little four-person round
robin where you know if you get the
invite 20 years in a row you can pick up
five titles it it is an open slugfest
with hundreds of players you know
whoever the sharpest teenagers are that
year
they're showing up
um yeah I don't offhand know of anyone
with more than three titles
oh yeah I mean hundreds of players are
signed up for that it's a world
championship event
so
yeah I I imagine that he has more titles
than Magnus I maybe they both have three
someone would have to verify that I
would bet that MPL has two
um
maybe more
yeah all right they're probably like two
the position yes they've gotten out of
this opening is very interesting so
black has played G6 E6 typically not
something you want to do right because
you're weaken the square however I guess
this was the only way to uh to sort of
keep everything protected now maybe he's
gonna develop with Bishop E7 and later
kick this Knight out
yeah it's a it's a really tricky thing
in these um I mean black blacks
basically playing like uh
an English because it's a symmetrical
English you more often see white playing
the d-pawn and getting this kind of
space Advantage but there's a tricky
thing where you want to bring the bishop
to G7 and then the C5 Pawn gets tagged
and uh there's a lot of lines in the
main English that are based on the same
thing
he goes F5 right away
so
kicking this night out but at the cost
of weakening both the E6 pawn and maybe
the E5 Square
right
castles might already run the risk of
something like Knight D5 and
this diagonal could open up
yeah I was calculating Knight G5 here as
well but it didn't quite hold up yeah me
too me too it's
I think it's just going to be D3 but
we'll see yeah maybe you start with G3
yeah you start with D3 just developing
our position a little bit more
if you try too hard to win with three
pieces and then like you have no way to
use your Rooks or your C1 Bishop
it has a habit of not working out
yeah generally a good idea to put all
your pieces into the game first and then
start some action
D3
um this could also introduce the idea of
E4 by the way like if black has to play
a terrible move like H6 to stop bishop
or Knight G5
and I would think after E4 white should
have the advantage just
Tempo one is so would you even sacrifice
the d-pawn
I would yeah
there I'd be confident well the white
pieces were gonna
come swarming out
yeah I think we're more likely to see
something conservative
Bishop either to G5 or D2 and Rook C1
Target the C Pawn
yeah okay so he placed King h8 getting
off that diagonal but he does give white
the option of you know bishop or Knight
to G5 with the tempo and I would guess
bringing out the new piece is going to
be the better of the two moves but I'm
not sure
yeah Bishop 5 is calling out to me
um I'm not sure to keep D5 defended
that's not pleasant
right because I guess she's going to D6
these six but it's vulnerable there like
you'll have some Knight B5 ideas some
Knight D5 Bishop of four
so I definitely like this position for
grish uh for ding after Bishop G5 you
know
and I still just want to play E4 for
white and blow it open I'm really I'm
really you're willing to you're willing
to check all these pawns away yeah I
mean I'll play Bishop G5 first here
right to get the queen D6 tempo of
course
yeah
I'm not trying to be stupid just a
Madman
all right I see so Queen D5 is another
sort of strange move to me like looks
weird yeah I looked at Queen B5 and
queen C4
they both seem to make black play Queen
D6
trying to think I guess if Queen yeah if
queen or queen D6 you will get a Tempo
yeah either with Bishop G5 on Queen E7
or or Knight to five Bishop F4 there is
no B3 here
Knight C3 BC yeah and then take it oh
you just want to take okay I'm worried
that it'll open up this diagonal it will
it will
the move I would
probably go with this queen B6 because
I'm worried that my king is weaker so an
end game
feels like my best hope
yeah that move makes a lot of sense
white spent two moves on their Queen
you're only spending one so you're
regaining some time and energy if they
trade
um
sinking into thought here this is the
Sasha we know and love
down two minutes
I was gonna say that in the first part
of this match
he it's been sort of 50 50 on the clock
there were two games where he was well
ahead in two games where he was well
behind um I think in all four games
White
had a comfortable lead on the clock in
that sense this game is still
fitting that pattern
that's right yeah it hasn't been nip and
tuck on the clock one side usually takes
an early like one to two minute lead and
keeps it
and I feel like the trend we're seeing
is the person with more time is
is uh successful so at some point I
expect them to start speeding up getting
into a better rhythm man allowing Bishop
G5 that like Queen E7 wasn't truly on my
radar of moves that might get played
yeah what
he's down to 20 seconds what's the plan
well the plan is to get down to 10
seconds and then start firing out moves
and then tell us the plan
here I'm worried about Knight D5 Bishop
4 and Rook C1
definitely a good
time it is time to make that trade
because if black is able to trade on C3
of course it favors white but it'll
prevent any immediate disaster on the C
file
because black really wants to play this
move B6 yeah which is why I like Bishop
F4 to kick to relegate the queen
um and then you go Rook C1 and there's
no more B6
yeah and there's no more seat on either
that's just
crystal clear and ding has the time to
spend spending
gobs of time by Chris shook standards
right he's got a whole minute here to
think about the continuation he's going
to find an advantage for white
yeah the only thing about this line I'm
realizing is you can't take on E2 at the
end
and then B2 would be hanging so it's
still interesting
um
I guess it's like Queen C5 and you get
enough com counter play along the E file
but ding has to work these lines out
however if you don't go for that line
and you allow B6 then black is
completely fine so yeah he does go for
this
expecting Rook C1 here
yeah I guess you could go rookie one
first
foreign yeah nothing wrong with rookie
one honestly I would guess that doesn't
spoil the advantage at all right yeah
because you're saying that the threat of
Rook C1 is stronger than the execution
no need to allow
black uh to gobble these two pawns yeah
I mean we're saying like how does black
stop Rook C1 and we've got a second
thread of E4 I know you think like I
can't get my mind out of the E4 but no
you really seem like a secondary threat
like if we like
like if blacks has some
did he just play it yes
black has some move that somehow defends
you know C5 and C6 here I would think E4
could be a good winner
five four okay night before
oh so we looking at this yeah this is a
very good move because now he's got B6
and Bishop D7 areas to trap the queen
yeah where is she going
rishik might be back in the game B2 is
hanging
as well
similarly
so we can't use like E4 to just lever
the queen out because we'll lose a rook
to Queen takes E1
plus D4 probably B6
wait takes it wow
he didn't have a lot of time there he
has two seconds total and that was after
two seconds got added to after a second
got added to the clock but now ding
suddenly low on time so those two
minutes you had have vanished yeah used
all of it
foreign
now it's a bit of a mess like maybe a
slight Edge for white because Black's
Pawn F Pawn Advanced but
black caught up in development
Running on Fumes here two seconds wait
but three seconds for ding this is
insane yeah Queen d3h5 is a threat
in D2 okay H6 is hanging H6 oh
that hurts could be a rook C7 oh but
he's just winning all the pawns three
pawns one two three
yeah the position just totally collapsed
queen of 4X C7
oh they're up to see one
four seconds should be enough time for
Dean to convert this pretty smoothly oh
he gives a B6 though
you get wait there's Queen D6 there
was Queen B6 yeah
all right now he simplifies it should be
fine
Bishop B7 here
yeah
yeah it was good enough but very shaky
technique I think Queen B6 would have
been a double attack
but he does get get the wind there I
mean he had three pawns I wouldn't say
he was too shaky in the bullet he always
had
he always I don't know but he didn't did
I not have Queen takes B6 because your
Rook on C7 was hanging and I had Queen
takes F2 and queen H2 mate
so I think that would have really
thrown something in the works
okay
man now they're going at bullet speed
Yeah by that game I think it's safe to
say we're gonna see an adjustment
because that sort of time management is
not sustainable for either side I feel
yeah I remember
okay some players like neho just like
getting low on time for the thrill of it
but if I'm getting low on time uh two or
three games in a row
I'm just gonna like start
panicking uh
completely losing my mind so I hope for
the Player's sake that they speed up a
bit
yeah even players who like that feeling
I think that they are still going to
recognize that having five seconds
against three minutes
and yeah might not be the best idea it's
just
it's not conducive to scoring the most
points like there's just a point at
which that's not strategically good
so Grisha going back to this Marshfield
worked very well for him
now seems like a slightly different
approach they traded Knights
mm-hmm
but once again
well you have to be careful yeah still
quite quite loose for black MSA
95 ideas Bishop F4
how about trying to solve all our
problems with violence with C5
whoa
so you're saying you've got Bishop F6 if
I take yeah
that would have been something USB
should be seven instead
now if Bishop 4 I guess he wants Bishop
D6
hmm sure yeah
and if 95 maybe it's Bishop D5 so he
wants to neutralize White's activity
now I'm not sure how does white increase
the pressure
because those are the two most natural
moves 95 Bishop F4 but black seems to be
ready I'm also looking at A5 ideas try
and undermine the Knight
maybe bishop F4 Bishop D6 Bishop G5
and then making use of the fact that you
don't have F6 and if I go Queen D7 then
we expect like Queen D7 and maybe just
plop the Knight on E5
that would force me to take trade yeah
it would force me to take it but then my
Bishop opens
um I guess I can show that line briefly
yeah so Queen d785 I take it
and I'm worried that
this bishop could start to to shine
right
so he goes the other way certainly
opened
three a five
and now 95.
the bishop on E3 I don't see its
prospects there
I guess it's just restraining black from
putting a piece on D5 that's its job for
now I think so and at some point you
might want to take it and fight for the
C6 Square
um
but definitely not now because you would
run into the skewer
oh yeah or even go completely light
square like there could be some scenario
if there weren't Bishop takes B4 where
you play Bishop B4 a B4 Queen C4 yes you
dominate D5 and you pressure F7
we could see that because Bishop D6 but
as long as black has Bishop B4 it's hard
to arrange maybe
um
so if there's a way for white to put
their Queen on you know C4 or H3
themselves first yeah I'm also trying to
organize some form of attack
you can always double
with rookie three
how should you position your piece as
though
Rook C1 is on the table
um
I think Richards found the right area to
um combat this match for his next few
whites I think this is like a promising
territory
yeah it's
definitely a trigger position for black
always with so many weaknesses like F7
A5 to C6 Square you can always blunder
um various things
yeah but it's open it's open and
tactical there's not like one solution
for black
I'm wondering if black also has
attacking prospects
I would be hoping so with those Bishops
rookie 3 is the move I wanted to play
but it runs right into Knight D5
which would force me to part ways with
my
uh really beautiful Bishop
so I don't want to play rookie three
what are what are the moves here Queen
H3 Maybe
you mentioned this move but that would
allow hp5
Rook ad1 there's another move Rook ad1
can't be bad yeah you get your last
piece into the game
I mean it could be if I were blundering
something with the bishop 183 you know
if like Knight D5 or something were a
problem uh-huh yeah but I think
it's probably reasonable like Knight D5
there maybe you just take it and A5
would be hanging
yeah so yeah I like Rook 81 he does play
it
but that was
this is the first game where White
does not have the time advantage that
was two minutes and zero zero seconds
we're seeing these lawn things yeah and
they're just not going to be affordable
especially in the three minute when you
only have three minutes so that would be
two-thirds of your time
right
um Jeffrey quick question before they
get into another bullet time scramble uh
you're a big fan of of sports and as the
match was getting started people were
discussing whether or not chess is a
sport so I'm just curious like your take
on that for me it's actually it's always
been a mind game for me
so I'm not sure sports or not no mind
games are Mind Games yeah I wouldn't
consider it like certainly not uh okay
it can be physically demanding this we
all know like
um during the game you're expanding so
much
so much energy that it can be even
more taxi than other sports but somehow
I I consider this a mind game I consider
it an art but not technically a sport
okay so for you a sport the focus has to
really be on your physical capacities
versus somebody else's even though in
physical Sports people
like have to have a mental game as well
yeah someone says it's a metal sport
this is a very accurate assessment yeah
okay
um but I am keeping yeah I'm keeping an
eye on everything I like to multitask
I've got yeah I've got the Belgian
Morocco game running
right now while we're there's Heather's
tabs on it I'm keeping tabs on it yeah
it's a very important game but you're
not commentating that for like FIFA or
something no I'm I'm yeah unfortunately
FIFA didn't hire me but yeah
yeah all right well there's a threat to
the king side from Black
he said black would want to attack as
well G2 Under Fire
right this could be dangerous
uh do you have to go D5 here shutting
down the bishop I don't know about have
to but you want to right isn't that like
I'm very more space in the center maybe
you can get away with F3 and after Queen
G5 G3
yeah but that those now you're talking
moves I don't want to play I don't want
to move every Pawn in front of like
usually not the best concept yeah he
does go D5 here you can't take it
because of Knight C6 at the end
yeah
and no matter what black does I mean
like Knight C6 is a very very big
concept from White here uh you know
looking to reopen the bishop on B3 open
the two files for White's Rooks maybe
even get into the seventh rank at D7 or
E7
pressure of the F7 Square
yeah black doesn't show something I'd
still much prefer white the one thing
concerning though is 22 seconds against
a minute and 30.
yeah we've seen that that does matter
already this match
um
we had a couple time scrambles and the
player who was in time trouble first
often suffered or I think every time
yeah
but we'll see maybe
maybe 20 seconds will be enough for
grishek to handle this one
now as ding what other moves do you have
like Queen G5 G3 I don't see the
follow-up
yes I'm super
super worried about like a knight F7
and I guess it doesn't quite work yeah I
did I don't know if it doesn't work D6
also less fancy but D7 but looks no no
but D6 opens the bishop then I think
Queen G5 would be may he plays G3
um hang on a second can I take on D5 now
because with the e-file tension it seems
so
he does do it Queen C5 played oh
I forgot about this move maybe
yeah gotta play it doesn't look great
but
you do what you must
yeah
Knight takes C6 recovering the pawn and
that Knight is not going to be as good
as the bishop in this position and there
are back rink ideas now so Bishop C6
Queen C6 rookie one rookie one Rook B3
you have uh something on E8
what's going on here I guess white is
better
do you have to take and like play night
yeah no night before can't be right okay
it takes first Knight F6 right
now it's a simple technical situation
two weaknesses a five and F7 Superior
Bishop
yeah perhaps Rook C8 Force Queen
be five and maybe like some
Queen D4 or queen D2 okay Queen A6 is
nice
I'd love to move my H Pawn if I've got
time he does
move the Rook somewhere yeah Rook C5
okay they do simplify it
should be relatively balanced here yeah
it should be drawable now stops Knight
G4
wants to play rookie seven to A7 Maybe
but you have to keep F2 defended whoa
thing barely executed that move oh my
God
I think the connection there has got to
be some sort of lag like a delay because
he was way too slow there at the end
yeah yeah
and the situation was pretty simple he
was making small moves on one side of
the board
yeah that's very unfortunate
I have to say
all right so keeping the match tied
keeping the match tied
um and uh four wins for white so far in
six games
but now as ding I feel like when you
know your connection might Spike at some
point
that means you've got to play even
faster early on like
you have to play essentially 30 seconds
quicker than you normally would yeah
and psychologically that can be
extremely difficult
yeah and I see a little bit of a
reaction from tank he's he's thinking
about
or he's feeling a little bit about what
just happened there
yeah for on for online just in the
internet connection is
is sort of
um
becomes a really important factor in
this yeah this kind of stuff that's like
part of your equipment right to a tennis
match you bring sneakers and a racket
yeah it's maybe maybe like a headband
and here you bring a mouse and a mouse
pad and the internet connection
I remember when I was I played something
in China I was there for the Chinese
League
and there was a five-star hanging sorry
yeah it is hanging uh this is Theory I
think it's like you take everything and
uh you get compensation along the
diagonals okay but yeah I was saying
okay
uh I think it was like 2016 Chinese
League I'm staying at a five-star hotel
and they claim to have very good Wi-Fi
but when I boot it up it's like one bar
so even the best hotels in China can be
Troublesome uh with the connection
yeah it's interesting China is like
super modern in all kinds of ways World
leading and all sorts of Technologies
um it's a little bit surprising that
that would still be
a consistent problem
so now I'm wondering can I go D4 yeah
plays it
everything's getting simplified here
liquidated
53 yep no no go ahead
yeah I was going to say Bishop V3 I
think I can take
Queen B3 and go Bishop V6 give you the B
pump but I have enough uh play here to
to restore material
yeah you just open up all the Bishops
and there's no squares for the Rooks too
to hold the pawns together
um I was gonna say I I noticed a moment
in the opening where Grisha seemed to be
sort of like unhappily sort of like
looking to the left and right and when
players look away from the board I
usually think they're trying to sort of
like access their mental database
of opening Theory and he looked towards
like unhappily sort of what is this
what's that and then he just figured it
out I think
yeah it can be annoying position to play
with black because white has the
I mean it's symmetrical and white has a
Tempo up and if they get the first sort
of active play it can be very unpleasant
so now Knight C5 asking a big question
if you take on B2 there's Rook P1 and
Knight B7
so
not so easy for black
holding up on the clock so far no two or
three minute things for him this game
yeah Queen E7 runs the risk of
rookie one and white lines up
The Rook here
he has nowhere to go just yet
that is true yeah I wouldn't have a good
discovery
but just having it in the air can be
nasty
now as black how do you
finish your development because I'm
worried the moment I move this bishop
there's going to be ideas connected with
Queen A4 Knight B7 also a bishop D4
mm-hmm
yeah I believe this is really unpleasant
you never want to take on B2
Rook date is helping me
I really wouldn't know what to do as
black
how about uh Rook
B8 Bishop F4 Queen C5
yeah rugby might have
like ran into some C6 Bishop
before it is he goes rookie instead
and now there's massive pressure on B7
tough tough position here for grishek
um
how do you even
how do you even make moves because it's
just Rook C1 next coming for white
there doesn't even need to be anything
concrete right away
yeah that doesn't stop Rook C1
and the position is Flowing it's just
playing itself here for white
yeah if black doesn't have anything
white can play H4 H5 before they break
through on B7
I think you've got a triangle Queen B6
and relieve some pressure
otherwise I don't even see another move
can't move this Knight no good squares
for the bishop B7 is hanging Rook ba is
running into Bishop F4
and Rook d8 also doesn't have good
squares
yeah unfortunately after Queen B6
I think Queen A4 looks very nice from
Wayne
uh and you still have this discovery
sheesh just keeping pieces on the board
avoiding the trade and yeah there's
the Queen's not comfortable for black
anywhere maybe she goes to A5 next but
yeah this is almost as bad as it can get
with even material
all of white spaces are better than its
counterparts
foreign yeah I really like this queen A4
move playing Super concrete chess you
throw at Knight B7 once again anytime
black takes
I just go Rook B1 and
he is thinking here
um I don't I wouldn't want to simplify
with Queen B6 Knight B7 even if I even
if I'm up a pawn that just lets black
off the hook and you develop that Rook
on A8 it gets down to eight exactly
yeah I really like this queen A4 move
maybe there are other versions of it
there is there's Queen C4 is pretty
simple yeah
Queen C4 looks
also good oh he takes a B7 wow what is
this oh right because the bishop hits
the queen he forces the trade oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
that was deep
that was deep and apparently it's all
correct because the engine still lights
this for white wow
yeah that what a solution thing okay
that's the first
that's the first electrification that is
the first election yes I am Shell
Shocked by that decision the first we
didn't see it coming
whoo
that is sweet so for example Queen B2 or
a21 C6 with the Knight he could also
take with the bishop and go Bishop F4
I'm not sure which one he wants mm-hmm
um yeah either one could be good enough
potentially but yeah grishwick is still
stunned as well he's like Frozen it's
under 20 seconds
okay he does take Knight C6
now 97 is a huge threat if you go
Buffet oh there's Bishop D4
yeah you'd think king h8 would be the
only move there okay okay there's rugby
one exactly yeah maybe he wants queen C3
but Rook C1 there
yeah or 97 Bishop B7 so yeah Rook B1 is
winning material yeah exactly this is
winning material for sure
okay so that I mean Bishop B7 was no
issue that's yeah but I don't think
there was anything you could have done
so now either Rook C1 or 97 both picking
up the piece
wow what a brilliant piece uh Queen SEC
from yeah ding nice
beautiful stuff
yikes all right so that was an
unpleasant experience for uh krishak he
needs to just shake that game off real
fast
yeah first flash of Brilliance I feel in
the match and I think we're gonna see
plenty more
yeah
now what do you think of uh Grisha going
for uh E4 again
well I think it's a good decision yeah I
mean he's won both
back-to-back games and we see ding
switching to the Berlin which he
I don't think he plays this nearly as
often than the Marshall if I'm not
mistaken
okay Bishop V7 with Knight H4
yeah I believe it's Knight H4 here we've
seen this mvl has already played this a
million times for white
you can
I think
cake it and then you probably put the
bishop either on F4 and E3
okay give us a check first
uh that makes sense because if you don't
give if you don't give that check you
give black the uh the time to play
Bishop E6 and then King C8 ah and go the
other way yes B6 King and get a Rooks by
throwing in the check here you force the
king to stay in the way of
the Rooks connecting
and he wants to meet Bishop fight with
Knight D4
so as Dean you can play Flex moves yeah
I like Bishop V7 I like H5 later on and
then you can often delay where you put
your Bishop on C8 yep G4 yeah
okay now I would want to put the bishop
on this diagonal to pressure on F3
however Bishop E6 is running into a
knight F4 which I don't like
so do you start with a move like B6
not sure how you how you want to do this
I mean the king's going to be able to
defend F3 why why is it so right yeah
you're right you're right no no that is
that is a fair point okay no I was I was
curious I thought maybe there was some
there's one other idea here you can take
and play F5 this one I've also seen
yeah I've seen that played
another thing is a5a4 Rook A5
okay
yeah there are a few things
to choose from oh that looks pretty cool
oh you like this one I I like The Rook
on A5 yeah because you can also just
swing it over to D5 right and try and
simplify
all right it takes first which should
always be good opening up this other
Rook yeah
it's Black's worst piece right so you
came up with something good to do with
it that made me happy
true I guess uh he does go with the F5
he takes with the pawn which I was not
expecting I thought he wanted to take
with Bishop there
but okay this one
or
and now I would like to play F5 and keep
opening up
the king yeah I think black maybe plays
King F7 here
and then against Bishop C7 F5
aha
so oh there is this concept here after
F5 G5 let's say Rook G8 yeah can you
how do you do this like maybe King F2
and you just sacked the pawn maybe King
two
just fight for compensation here yeah
like Knight F4 and maybe Rook H1 yeah
uh-huh yeah now those now that Bishop is
really bad in the Brooklyn a it's really
bad so that's why you want to start with
King F7 and not allow that idea
yeah
makes sense to me
oh but he goes F5
okay we're gonna see this line
King F2 wow it's playing it really
confidently so yeah it's pure I think
it's pure intuition he knows that after
it takes Knight F4 he's down a pawn but
this beautiful night
on F4 cannot be touched he's got Rook H1
so I think we're gonna see this line
yeah I think he I think he was uh double
checking this idea while while ding was
thinking because he just true I believe
so I believe so yeah
I really like this though you go Knight
F4 you can go Rook H1 you can also go
like Rook D3 and Rook E1 try and just
use these two open files in the center
Knight F4
yeah I don't
yeah by the way I just want to say I
don't want Rook H1 because that would
allow Bishop E6 so yeah Knight F4
yeah also any other move would allow
black to play f for I mean F4 is very
desirable for black there and at least
get rid of that extra Pawn but be able
to move to Pieces yes
seven do you go Rook D3 or do you go
Rook H1
yeah I mean it's the big question Rook
D3 Rook D2 something like that is my
instinct rather than Rook H1 because
that Bishop on D7 is so vulnerable I
wanna oh I love it I love Rook D3 and
the reason is because I can also go put
the other Rook on each one and you'd be
tied down to this vulnerable Bishop as
you're as you as you were saying
yeah it starts with location one okay
now as black can I get away with King F7
here
clever
so I've got Rook G7 on Rook H7 and on
Rook D1 maybe I play like Bishop E8
looks yeah it looks like E8 yeah that
looks flimsy like the moment I said it
the one I said it yeah oh but you don't
have rook d8 in those positions because
Rook H7 Rook G7 trade in 96. exactly
exactly yeah so he does play this wow
so first of all there's Rook H7 Rook G7
take take 96 96 to C7 but
I don't think I feel like you want more
than that
um how did you know how did you know I
always want more
okay Rook H7 is a huge threat
um tell us why is that a huge threat
so the point is like now if Richard
seven I take and I win C7 with my Rook
which is a huge
huge Plus for me and then you've got
this Undisputed Rook on the seventh Rank
and that's enough to
pretty confident you're winning I'm not
sure about winning but I have
excellent winning chances yeah and
meanwhile you don't have a nice move
because Rook d i you're always worried
about the fork
Bishop D7 obviously not possible so what
what is your move even I have another
plan for white here other than Rook H7
which is to go rookie five and Rook H E1
I like it yeah rookie by the way okay
like sorry about E7
Roxy was a very calm move just defending
the pawn but now I do like your idea a
lot with rookie 5.
everything
oh man is mentioning 96 here
96 in Rook H7 oh yeah and it can't be
stopped either
that looks good
hmm
yeah many attractive things I still like
your rookie five one simply five it
would be like or rookie maybe six yeah
maybe seven
uh yeah that's why I'm saying maybe you
start rookie three instead just so
you're never hit with uh with King F6
so I like rookie three as well I like
Knight E6 I'm sure both moves are
promising
now grishek shouldn't spend too much
time though I would keep you know 20 30
seconds ahead just because I'm sure
we'll be in a Time scramble later and
you want the extra time to have during
some certain moments unless you're
actually caught calculating just an
absolute knockout that we haven't right
but if it's just a move to increase the
pressure like Rook H6
then that move you you want to save your
time on so I think it's the same idea
Rook H easy yes he wants to jump off
King E6
cutting off cancer yes
okay King G8 preparing Rook G7 and oh
and now he doubles the on the other side
okay
we have seven
um
I don't see anything concrete
me neither
I still don't like trading a rook I
think it's really good to keep both
Rooks on the board for white here I
totally agree yeah I want to keep all
the material on it should be hard for
black to find moves like even if I make
a random Pawn push like B4 it's very
hard for black to find moves I guess
here Knight D3 could be another move for
white trying to find time for F4 I see
yeah I see the benefit of that oh and he
does do it yeah well I like my 99 F4 a
lot more
but I see I see yeah you got 95 and F4
Maybe
okay
basically it it sort of breaks Black's
plan setup with the Rook on G7 yeah I I
was certain he would throw that yeah you
were hinting at this F4 Pawn sacrifice
earlier he just wants to Chuck it and
now he at least gets the square for his
Bishop which is nice
I think we'll see Bishop's life no he
doubles first
now yeah all the pieces out oh there
goes the wind
I think this is still easier for white
to play right because we got the past
that pawn against Double C
okay yeah well I'll I'll concede that if
I were playing black white would still
have winning chances but I don't think
against uh against dang that this is
enough all right grishek is gonna
simplify this completely
now
I still feel like there should be some
winning chance for white like you dance
with the Knight
um
forever
before he had Bishop F5 if not for
Bishop F5 you know key 45 can I go P4
though because most pawn names are gonna
be winning
yeah now right now he gets it P5 maybe
or Knight D5
this is close this might be winning
now it looks winning now it looks just
completely over wow
yeah I told you that that position
practically might just always be losing
because I've got to pass that pawn
against Deadwood Pawns
even though the position just like it
yesterday but I thought like at this
level you know no no we're all the same
I remember I remember my coach told me
uh when I was a kid everyone plays sane
Everybody Plays the same Everybody Plays
the same yeah it doesn't matter if it's
you or Magnus Everybody Plays same it's
purely psychological
okay this is okay this is obviously
something you told me when I played
against higher rated players so I don't
worship them or over respect them but
I'm telling you like
people give certain players more credit
than they deserve like you would think
that they're seeing everything but
they're actually not this is some
Insider info I'll give you all right
it's good to know
I mean it's not going to help me not
lose when I have that position but at
least I'll think like instead of
thinking like any other player would
have drawn this I'll think like yeah
that's a tough position ding might have
lost it too
yeah and I saw the engine was giving
like triple zeros but I knew that was
not the case
okay
so yeah we might see the same line here
oh it's slightly different slightly
different uh grishek played E6
in the other game right
so now here also it's like it's gonna be
thematic like if you castle and black
plays Bishop G7 it's like Queen B5 from
White going after that sleep one
uh you mean queen B5 or 94.
uh either one uh
my point is just if White Castle's
normally here in Black plays Bishop G7
it's like going after the C Pawn is
really
yes and I'm recalling a game from the US
Championship Shanklin caruana was it
like this yeah but that that one was
with esex yeah
but wasn't it e69 oh no Knight was still
on D5 you're right yeah
so now if E6 there's 95 so how do you
solve the problem
oh wow apparently this is how you solve
it you just give it up yeah
maybe he wants Bishop G4 Rooks C8
hmm sounds a lot of it in the this
happens a lot in the English yeah but do
you buy into this compensation sure now
it's like he's playing the black
Redeemer I mean
certainly in a Blitz game I do
issue E6 Rook C8
I don't know White's Queen really wants
to get to C2
well I'm fine with putting the queen
over here on the side too like what if I
just go Bishop E3 Rook C1
oh
f8 yeah yeah exactly
okay but mystery five I like this two F6
would be
a disaster if black would have to play
it but he does do it hold on no problem
he really wants to trap ding's Queen I
feel something like Bishop E3 Bishop V6
and then Bishop fade and A6 with trap
yeah but also like what's the disaster
like he's willing to play like F5 at
some point if he wants to as long as his
Bishop
on C8 is on is alive and can control the
D5 square and stuff he'll be
okay yeah you totally disagree yeah
I I mean
I'm
seeing like a future D4 coming in I
don't know
all right so let's take an inventory of
the squares the White Queen has
available right now
B5
if black played Bishop f8 there's B5
left well the good news the good news is
the name B6 is hanging and then after A6
you could play Queen takes B6 right
um
was that time just now for the five
minute section I think yes it will be
this will be the last game in the five
minute yes okay so the score is four to
four this last game will
count
and then they'll have a break before
three minute chess mm-hmm
being allowed this Knight D4 jump a
little bit prematurely I feel but okay
he's gonna go for this position should
still be a bit better
yeah
it's Queen still not trapped so that's
good news and Knight C5 could be coming
and Rook C1 Black's gotta prove
something here
well Knight survive there's a bishop D5
and maybe you're starting to unwind this
for black
you can also put the Knight on D2 or G5
um where would we be going if we put it
on G5 yeah G5 seems like we're stuck in
the middle of nowhere maybe Knight D2
okay it goes Knight C5
yeah so I guess Supreme Square Bishop D5
just rookie one he wants
the bishop is very
strong in the middle I think if Dean can
can play he'd go Knight H4 and swap
these Bishops
okay Rook C8
maybe start with Rook C1
black something to prove if white can
keep that Knight on C5 if white can play
Rook C1 and B4 and stuff then blacks
just I mean they're down a pawn
struggling to defend D4 and B7 it could
be really bad here
that is true
yeah I like
I think both moves are good here because
I'm noticing this Square on A5 for the
queen could be quite decent
yeah so yeah I like
I like either Rooks winner before just
to uh protect the Knight
yeah is there Bishop H6 against Rolex C1
that might harass The Rook yeah
[Music]
um
I guess he's just going to C2 yes
trying to figure out if I can do
something for black connector with A6
but doesn't seem like that's an issue
he plays rookie seven okay so this has
ideas of doubling also playing Knight D7
and the dream would be to maybe win back
a Pawn on C5
mm-hmm but I don't think you're getting
anywhere this I can go Queen A5 and B
for worst case
yeah and that takes out the Knight D7
idea
84. so I guess A6 he's got Queen B4 and
A5
hmm
not sure what to make of this it looks
okay so if black doubles here what's he
playing I think it's just A5 just A5 and
then Knight to D7 97 sometimes I can
even take there because your Bishop
would be hanging
mm-hmm
then yeah Queen takes Queen takes and
white wins everything okay
so yeah tactically I guess ding has
worked it out
um I would play
A6
I would never have played A4 I would
have been yeah yeah so busy defending my
stuff so terrified
I would be worried as well but maybe
this is all just fine like after A6
Queen before D4 is suddenly loose
so I was trying to line up some Bishop
fate but I'm never in time
I guess we played A6 then Rook c7's off
the table because the Knight on B6 needs
to be defended right
okay
yeah no Rook C7 is annoying here
um no Bish Buffet either
so what else can black try
sure
Chuck's not sure and he's down to 30
seconds here
okay for the night
yeah
you don't really care
all right Queen V3 check
okay I guess now he's gonna put the
queen on A3
B4 seems good
maybe repeat once
you can always repeat once yeah
now how does he want to deviate here
I think you can still go A5 like I again
I'm not afraid of Knight D5 because the
Knight doesn't really have any entry
squares
so Queen B3 probably kha and now can I
go Knight G5
that's top of the list yeah
I feel like I would have a lot of
tactics looming and he does play
like if Queen D6 maybe there's some
brilliancy with Knight B7 because a lot
of stuff is hanging here
yeah I'm getting ready for that I mean
he could even just go into E6 anyway
after Queen D6 oh right there are all
sorts of pins takes takes takes and you
just take on D5 yeah this is winning for
sure you can I think you can take on A6
you can probably take on B7 if you're
crazy yeah um and also this like you
said there's got to be a tactic
right Knight B7 Rook B7 you have Queen
B7
exactly yeah because everything's loose
oh that's beautiful actually let's show
it really quick
so
this now you get rid of the defender and
Knight of seven comes and he does find
it
that's a dagger and Bishop B7 everything
falls apart as well very simple you just
trade on C8 and take it I think he's
back exactly yeah you just keep it
simple here
it's just over
another really nice tactical flurry at
the end okay ding just using
just checking maybe he has a brilliancy
but yeah he just goes for the simple one
yeah yeah
that should be lights out I think you
check maybe Knight D6
do you go Queen B8 here
okay
okay all right grishek's still fighting
but it shouldn't be too difficult to
convert this one yeah well I like that
move
ideally ding still wants to like maybe
play Bishop C4 but okay he covers Rook
B5 okay he may win one Pawn back all
right I'm worried about Dean's
connection though that's I'm always
worried about this that's right
like if it spikes out of the blue
okay now he's got Rook C7 Queen F7
Bishop G4 that should be it yeah Rook C8
game over
wow all right okay it wasn't even so
easy I mean with just a couple seconds I
think there is that like five ten
percent chance to uh to blunder it or
Mouse slip or flag but he holds on he
wins that game and he takes the five
minute Portion by one point exactly the
smarter chest prediction and
uh
uh I think smarter just was five and a
half three and a half so very close oh
it was two points you're right it was
two buds
but yeah actually I was the one that
said one point let me let me blow my own
horn a little bit
but it has been very back and forth
um yeah ding a lot of white victories I
think so maybe both players only white
victories so it could be argued that the
extra point is simply that uh things
started to match
yeah so I expect to see some adjustments
for black but yeah I think uh we will
take a break now and uh resume the three
minute portion
see you all soon
[Music]
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
.com's newest mobile release for Android
and iOS now with game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
welcome back everybody to the 2022 speed
chess championships on chess.com we have
finished up with the five minute portion
we have two time controls left to play
um Jeffrey what do you think of the
player's performance so far in the first
section compared to expectations
so it's about where we expected I think
being like a one or two point margin uh
was the precise prediction as we saw
from smarter chess he got the number of
games correctly as well I'll give him
slight tip of the cap for that but
in general from what I saw the quality
was fine but I think both players sunk
into long things too many times like as
I said earlier in the three minute
you're just not going to be able to do
that so hopefully they speed up the pace
get it find their Rhythm and we see a
lot of uh really close battles on the
clock in the three minute segment yeah
so do you feel like the overall match
um probability uh still makes sense of
around you know 63 64 percent
chances to ding does it still feel like
that or do you feel like it's been so
back and forth with white winning every
game that it might be a little more of a
toss-up even than that suggests I have a
snake snake is fishing that this is
gonna go down to the wire and the reason
I say that is because neither side
looked too convincing in the time
scrambles meaning even if one of them
has a winning position I'm not certain
that they're going to convert it
smoothly
and
yeah so
I think time management is going to be
the big thing in terms of opening um I
feel like both sides got a little bit
with white there
so yeah we'll just see how it goes maybe
we'll see some adjustments here
for me it's kind of like holding serve
at the moment right we've seen seven
white wins in a row I I believe wow on
and if I if gershot keeps winning with
white I'm gonna say like my default is
that actually the match is more or less
a you know 50 50 toss-up
um you know maybe I'm gifting like a
five percent
uh favorite because he always gets the
first White and because
um you know of how well he did in this
bullet match with uh with Nakamura last
year but to me so far looks really close
to 50 50 because
um grishek's been able to attack e45
into rui and just create chances every
single game with white and um
in contrast it still feels kind of like
yes but I'll argue with you like dings
White games have been Troublesome for
Grisha too right like the English
symmetrical
um he's always gotten a lead on the
clock and also pressure on the board so
yeah I think uh one other thing I wanted
to say
so oh wait sorry uh yeah they are
underway here
actually I forgot what I wanted to say
I'll let you know if it comes back to me
sure but we do see an anti-marshal here
with a485
yeah
I was expecting this also even though
that Berlin
um you know reached a position
where you know ding might have been okay
it felt like when he switched to the
Berlin uh gershook knew a little bit
better than him what to do with it and
that pawn sacrifice with the Knight on
F4 I think was not something that was
going to encourage ding to be like oh
let me you know go back to the Berlin
again
absolutely yeah I would agree with that
that position left with the Knight on F4
was not appetizing for Black by any
stretch yeah so we're back into sort of
main repertoire the sort of Marshall Lee
kind of and of course an anti-marshall
from White
I'm a bit surprised that grishek opted
for something else um I like this
position too though I will say but I was
expecting him to keep repeating that
line until Dean proved how to equalize
now for any idiots doing the commentary
or watching from home why is this Pawn
not hanging after bcbc Rook A5
no that's a very uh good question I
guess you would just take it
and maybe play Queen A1 try to win the
pawn back
um Queen b5c4
yeah I would assume it's this one
and I guess then white would have have
like a jump start on the queen side
sure if the White Queen and Rook get out
there first yeah I didn't see Queen A1
thank you very much
so yeah Queen City Queen is seven
instead maybe a knight C4
um stopping like a D5 advance
there's also D4 here by the way
right I mean he has
not played what to my mind would have
been the super obvious move Knight C4
for white
and so I guess it's because he's playing
for D4
yeah but he's leaving this Pawn hanging
like if you take with the pawn here okay
he doesn't but I was gonna save CD4
there might have been uh Knight A5
so that pawn does matter sometimes gotta
keep your eyes open
this is the confusing thing about super
GMS like sometimes they'll let you
take a pawn sometimes not and it can
sometimes be confusing because I don't I
cannot even tell the difference
um
but yeah
so probably Knight D4 Rook A5 would run
into uh nacion or meso here with Knight
C6 97 so you don't want to blunder that
yeah
I caught that one I wasn't gonna do that
I guess the reason why ding is so
hesitant is he doesn't like the
structure after 94 c84 and opening the C
file right yeah I mean now he's sort of
suffering on on C7 forever big suffer
but I I think he wants Bishop maybe
bishop d8 is fine
although no there's Queen C6
hang on a second
whoosh
I'm worried about Queen C6 here I am
like really surprised that both you and
dang like
that there was like an instinct that you
could just go this passive well I'm not
sure what else I could do right I
thought he was just gonna play like C5
take like say hey I already have a pawn
weakness but let me stay active
oh faster dc5 and Knight C4 there I went
yeah yeah he's so sure but here yeah I I
agree with you White's definitely better
after Queen C6 you don't even have to
play Queen C6 if you don't want to
right but I don't see another useful
move to be honest
oh rookie two okay he found one
love it I was thinking about you know
like playing F3 and King F2 as we trade
Queens you know somehow timing that with
Queen C6 but it's true that Rook B2
um was bothering me at all this is a
super GM very classy move and now
I mean you still don't need to play
Queen C6 if you don't want but I I would
do it like the end game seems very
promising to me
and if you wait around too long isn't
there some chance that black plays Queen
G6 and then you don't quite have time to
go take on A6 anymore mm-hmm
yeah I totally get what you're saying
in fact even here Queen C6 Queen G6 is
that unthinkable
so if I take on a630 it would take on e4
I'd take on e4 yeah and I'm saying you
know if you play F3 and I play I don't
know Rook B2 Maybe
some counter play yeah who knows
he plays Knight F3
so if Queen G6 what is the point now I
don't like E5 giving up the square
but I guess that's his idea
other ideas allow Queen takes E4 right
yeah
it is between that then I guess I will I
will give you the D5 Square then
um probably takes an id5 oh hang on a
second there's also a night before oh he
took with the other Rook okay but now
after Knight D5 A5 this is not this is
plainly not good for white yeah I think
he he's definitely misplayed this
slightly
um it still shouldn't be too bad either
unless
I'm wondering if there's an idea here
with like Bishop A5 and if Rook D6 maybe
Rook B1
yeah maybe Rook oh no he goes Rook B6
okay okay holding extra holding the
pawns so now the idea is just you know
maybe the a pawn could be better
um
in some of these end games
yeah all right Richard down to 15
seconds gotta hustle here a bit
are they just going to repeat or will
ding try Rook B1
now your ding yeah it's very
conservative in these moments yeah it's
reasonable remember what we said about
holding syrup right like yeah he loves
what he's getting with white that is
true yeah a draw is kind of like a break
here it consolidates a one-point lead
and now like for the first time in the
match I would truly say like he's got
the lead
yeah all right we got our first Catalan
this is all very standard Bishop Ford
Bishop G5 okay
now as black you can do a few oh this
one is
hang on a second is this correct because
sometimes if you allow white to play B4
it can get unpleasant but I guess this
is fine
probably black will go A5
right
yeah I don't understand too well the
bishop takes F6
how to lands
yeah you more or less you more or less
always get this type of structure where
there's really not a lot going on
um both sides Ultra solid but white
slowly tries expanding on on all sides
of the board like there could be
okay black normally takes on F3 at some
point and plays C6
and then we'll get this really slow time
maneuvering game although now he allowed
E4
there's gonna be slightly different to
what I was anticipating
yeah I'd been wondering about Queen D5
uh last move when he played Bishop B4
fighting for those Center squares yeah
and I hadn't you know fully calculated
E4 Knight e495 or something like that
um
okay so grisha's gonna concede not only
the center but also the bishop pair
yeah normally he would trade the C6
Bishop yeah because then C6 and keep the
dark squared one exactly that's more
solid and more drawish because you go
for upside Bishops
I'm worried he might be a bit worse he
really needs to keep up the pressure
against A4 and E4 because if he ever
gets pushed back by you know 95 and
stuff he can just end up under
oh yeah you can just end up much worse
here now
yeah you're absolutely right there's 95
being wasting no time now maybe just
Queen C3 to avoid C5 makes a lot of
sense
yeah it's got to be I'm even surprised
he thought on that particular vote
well it's always a question of how do
you progress like do you reroute the
night I mean do you re reposition the
night do you try and play B4 what do you
think is the long term yeah there's
always questions on those but like
before you get to those getting the
Queen off the D file you know playing
moves like B3 and Rook C1 and just
making sure the opponent's not playing
C5 those moves I feel are
the moves that you can play really
really quickly and then you come up with
how you want to torture the opponent
right like I totally agree yeah this is
a sort of the blueprint of how to play
good Blitz chess you make all these
useful moves that you know can't be bad
B3 Rook C1 maybe like an H3 even and
then on while your opponent's thinking
you can sort of form your your plan
right and then we can think you know
like hey maybe when you play B3 and Rook
C1 you'll see your opponents just give
up the move C6 that would be great to
know and see and then you probably want
to play with a knight C4 plan
you go after A5 you go after B6 and you
even introduce E5 Knight D6
um yeah and grishek is really taking a
sweet time here wow
if your opponent plays B6 maybe you just
look for like Knight C6 and a technical
conversion yeah B6 I would love to see
that as white
um
yeah he really can't find a movie
struggling yeah you see how long
krishnook is thinking here right that's
why when I'm white like Queen C3 is a
gimme he played it
you play it and you let your opponent
sort of like suffer and you see whether
they're playing Beast hang on hang on oh
if C5 there's D5 okay now I understand
because I was thinking you you plopped
the Knight on C6 but
if the if you're happy with D5 which
probably you are then there's no need to
hurry
I mean
yeah if you can keep C5 prevented
without playing Knight C6 then you could
even play for Bishop F1 to A6 but man
but this is insane hard to imagine he
just can't find moves right now down to
nine seconds against 209
sheesh
and Dean can do whatever he wants so you
can just pass you can play Bishop 3 h3h4
I mean whatever you want
I mean
um
okay it's not that easy to come up with
something
I don't know do you play like Bishop F3
King G2 here
just really maximize okay it goes Queen
E3 king of fate
um
double or not
we need to keep D4 defended
so I don't think doubling is going to
help White
but I guess we'll find out if that's
true
yeah
Queen D6 maybe oh but now he's allowed
Knight C6 hang on
whoa G4
ding saying the moment to strike is now
Queen G3 there's Rook D4 yeah 97 and
then Rook C7 oh
there is this is that a favorable trade
though because some I mean it looks
flashy but maybe black would take and go
Queen D6
uh they can't go Queen D60 oh they can
but he might play that because it's
complicated
you could also go D5 now he goes Queen
F4 threatening Knight G6 ready Knight G6
simple move
but krishak is fighting very well here
yeah
takes a knight of Fate tries to trap
that Knight
I had a fate
95 okay
um whoa that has to be a blunder oh
there was Knight C6 something with the
queen uh can you go Rook H3 though
this looks huge you've got Queen H4
that's a plan queen H4 is this just me
is this not me Knight G6 avoids check
oh but they're still Rook F3 oh okay
hold on yeah this should be wrote the
should be game over but it's not
there's not like a forced wind I don't
think so you guys wish F1 wow subtle
move and that's it
and that does it
boom
yeah he kept it under control there I
mean Grisha did well to fight on but
dropping all the way down to nine
seconds that early in the game not a
recipe for success
man that was aggressive that he chose to
go with G4 G5 that that game versus sort
of something more technical like Knight
C6 or I feel like it had to be related
to the time uh situation
because if grishek had a reasonable
amount of time he
probably plays more methodically but
like when your opponent has five seconds
makes sense just to go after
the king
so for all his high class you think ding
has that sort of
killer feeling of like here's a chance
to give my opponent some practical
problems totally I all of the elite
players have this yeah that Killer
Instinct to know when and when not to
strike
yeah
okay yeah I mean G4 G5 it's definitely
like a plan in the position it's not
it's not out of nowhere for those
watching look that that comes up and we
were talking how might black try to I
mean how might white try to crack in
that game it was on my list of ideas but
not the first idea
yeah
all right slightly different approach if
you remember the other game grishek had
the queen on C2 he puts it on E2 this
time
foreign
has always helpful to defend on A6 and
now A5 is hanging
the queen was good on C2 that game
though I mean I feel like the problem
was he just didn't pull the trigger on
that Queen C6 move agreed agreed yeah
and here I think you've got to go this
Knight C4 move right or not
you place this one again
so we're seeing a really similar game to
the previous uh
White right
and uh Rook A5 takes takes Rook a one
queen bee fine
Queen B5 and Knight B3 oh okay
this is almost the same game
just with the queen on E2 and maybe
right last game black would have just
doubled
yeah
he goes Bishop d8 again
and now I see that part of it is he just
wants to play C6 or C5 at some point and
tag the a pawn
he does have this
is that was sort of a resource that he
Unleashed as soon as they traded
Queensland scheme
true I think we're gonna see
a very similar approach no he does go C6
uh
interesting okay so I guess Queen C4
just Rooks C8
or queen C4 Rook a five
uh you're willing to even
yeah
I trade on D2 at the end and take E4
you're right that does work
so how else do you protect this like
Knight C4 drops the E Pawn
um okay so he's gonna go E5 first and
Knight C4
nice idea even to sack a pawn
but
look at these
three weaknesses here for black
95 big threat
okay
I really like this Pawn SEC from Grisha
I think it's harder
to play this for black
yeah I didn't even realize it was a pawn
sack when he played it I thought black
was just gonna play Knight five I didn't
even look at ah
you just trusted yeah
yeah
but
I'm very surprised why the engine thinks
there's triple zeros I would guess that
white is much better here
because there's all sorts of 95 ideas
bishop d8 and Knight B6 also Rook D1 is
lurking also you can swing this other
Rook to like E3 or G3
these ideas cover C6
you still set up for Knight B6
I really like this Rook A3 Rook A3 move
you want to come to D3 or E3 or G3 you
don't I'm not the
yeah yeah I'm not tied down to either
like straight for the E Pawn
King F7 is not advised so what's he
gonna do he's gonna just let the pawn be
and can now it's the B6 square if I want
to I can get the pawn back
right but I I sort of want to hold the
tension maybe with like Rook D1
takes it first
oh he does go for this simplification
not sure I like like the decision like
you're down by two points in the match
you want to start taking some risks
yeah I'm seeing Rook C5 here
ah 95 night of 95 Knight F4
that would be
a problem
so
what can I do then I don't know Knight
B6 yeah Knight B6 if you want I can play
Rook C2 or or whatever I I don't feel
very threatened to know yeah black is no
longer at risk for sure
I like this Rook C2 move
foreign
you can also get frisky with Knight F4
again
okay it's just gonna take
rookie three
and then is he gonna just play A5 yes I
think he does want A5
and he's saying that like so solid
there's like Rook B5 Rook A6 rookie well
yeah there is that but I think you could
go A5 Rook B8 Rook B5 just slowly
surround the B6 Pawn
um now the question is can grishek
organize pressure on G7 somehow with
like rookie one rookie seven or are they
just gonna repeat moves again
yeah I think this could be it right here
can I try rookie one I mean I'm down in
the match I want to take some chances
nope
not gonna try yeah
yeah this is a hard point to to search
for chances at this point in this Rook
end game I think
yeah sometimes something Messier earlier
I agree sometimes if you choose the
wrong position to over press
um you could be
putting yourself in a deeper hole it is
still a very long match there's still a
whole bullet segment two points
um can be erased quickly
yeah
all right slightly different version
hang on can't I take and take
or you're saying that I'm that I'm
slightly worse there
I would guess that you're definitely
worse there against the bishop pair with
white just playing Queen C7 no you can
put you can put it on the board if you
want oh you're right I forgot C7 is also
hanging yeah
no that would not be a wise thing
okay and if I if I take on D4
immediately
what happens like you take I take on G2
oh if you take on D4 immediately Knight
takes E4
no but E2 is 92 yeah be careful here
yeah yeah yeah so something like this
because I'm realizing
oh and it does go for it okay let's see
yeah
yeah 96 yeah so if fe6 very important
that after King G2 Queen D5 you have
Knight F3 yeah
it's a close call
um oh grishek might be considering to
move the queen here right like Queen D5
because if Knight C7 Queen G5
uh-huh but there is King G2 in that
position
whoa Queen D6
it's not afraid he's got Bishop F1
yeah but that Knight on C7 wouldn't be
and it would have been in bad shape
there
oh and the other line okay
but yeah this one I guess it's gonna
simplify like notify Bishop one Knight
F1 I'm expecting
and then Bishop Ford at the end of the
line Looks like we've got a few people
in chat who haven't been here since the
beginning so real quick
um there's three different time controls
that this match is played in we're in
the second time control the three minute
portion
um the players play out the full match
and uh you know the five minute portion
then the three minute portion and then
the one minute portion we have
37 minutes left in the in the three and
one right now and uh we've got a great
takes takes takes takes takes variation
on the board in front of us yeah Knight
H7 a shocker
uh apparently not liked by the engine
but as far as I can tell it seems good
you're winning a pawn
uh maybe bishop B2 Knight F6 he's got
94. like Knight F6 and 94 here
that must be his concept okay gf6
but night um or queen F5 what's so bad
uh
Uh Oh you mean in the other line or oh
no sorry I meant right here 94 Queen to
F5 an illegal move oh okay
let's let's replace that with a legal
move like Queen E5
yeah so
23 okay
yeah this is very messy
I think as black you have to take on G5
though undouble these pawns because if
you move the bishop and then
yeah like we need two and all kinds of
stuff
right right yeah oh he does Play Bishop
H5 which I was not expecting
because now isn't there like Bishop F4
super sharp this one like Queen B2
rookie one okay he goes Queen E6 more
safe
um if I take this Pawn
probably F5 is the response
yeah
I think you should develop The Rook I
don't know where or why maybe rookie
rookie one you meet F5 with Knight C3
that looks reasonable
slightly better here for ding I think
you've got the double F pawns I know
that I'm up against two Bishops but
past H bond that you have to reckon with
later
now here I wanted to play F3
oh F3 I'm not sure you have to though I
don't
if you're saying you want to I'm I'm
wondering hang on a sec I'm wondering
why I can't take on C7 now
because I've always got Knight C3 and
everything's protected
yeah
yeah you you can
I'm really wondering if black students
have taken on B2 when they had the
chance because
they've got this worse Pawn structure
and sometimes the safest thing is
to to make sure you have an advantage
somewhere on the board
yeah
hard he's working here maybe see
something after Bishop C7
um you can also go Knight C3 if you want
to play it safe
yeah but I guess your Bishop C7 is one
of the better questions
I still don't understand yeah I'm into
it I guess it's some Rook C8 you go
Bishop Ford back maybe there's like Rook
C4 I don't know I don't know
wow this is a lot of time
yeah too long
because this was not like a tactical
move here
hmm jinjutsu doesn't feel right to me
could be five
he wants to open the Rook oh and now you
remove F3 okay so he wanted to get out
of the way
yeah I might have been hanging the queen
or something who knows
okay Queen C3
still very complex
yeah
but black needs to do stuff on the queen
side I like the feeling of B5 yeah
there's a discovery here ah Rook bead
and Rook B3 also nice
yeah that could be very dangerous
okay Knight of two uh Queen where do you
put the queen oh Bishop B4
huge find here although there is Queen
C7 Queen C7 probably right this should
be one technical phase yeah but what is
how do you even evaluate this Knight
before there's Queen E2
eat very hard to play very very hard to
play for ding
Queenie two
I guess he's got Queen D4 wow Hanging On
by a thread
uh I want to transfer this bishop
somehow
that was really aggressive for Sasha to
keep the Queens on I gotta say that's
black
yeah I still have no idea what's going
on okay Queen three forcing the Queens
off oh white keeps offering the clean
trade yeah and probably it's a draw oh
and ghost opposites yeah that's good
that's good we got a solid draw and this
is for the first time
since the first game of the match that
uh gershook has held a game with black
oh wow ding won like four games four or
five games in a row with white with
white yeah yeah that is crazy white game
since game three of the match
[Music]
I think I think he needs to strike here
now because they made a few draws and
first time
he needs to take a quick break as do we
all that was half of the three minute
portion there's gonna be a very short
break folks and we will be back the
second half of the action see if
Christian can get back on the winning
streak with white
see you then
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back internet citizens we have
the speed Chess Championship uh round of
16 between dingley Ren and Alexander
grishook and uh we've got some chess.com
Blitz insights into their historical
games this is uh representing their
whole sort of online chess career at
chess.com we can see that for shook with
about eight times as many games played
as dingley Ren and what stands out to
you Jeffrey in these stats
yeah I remember I forgot my point
earlier that I was trying to make I
wanted to say in this like one plus one
specifically ding hasn't played any
games as far as I know this year
so that is a very pressing concern uh I
don't know how his Mouse skills and uh
yeah we can see that 52 percent of his
losses are coming by flag which seems
like an insane amount because this is
Blitz even not bullet so I imagine in
bullet it might be even more
uh more losses
yeah that losses by flag is apparently a
shocking stat to people other than me I
have just about the same
percentage on my own Insight I remember
seeing uh when I played the SEC match
um
and the commentators also were like
losing more than half your games just by
flagging yeah
I think it could also be he doesn't like
to resign very much so let's say he's in
a losing position late he'll just let
his time you could just take the time
run out yeah it could be this it's
possible but I know like for myself
I'll I I will resign with two seconds on
the clock if I'm down if I lose a piece
or something like that
um and I think we saw
uh one or two of the players do that in
this match already today under five
seconds and take the time to go resign
rather than let it just run out
okay and I'm curious do you ever look at
your opening lines during the break
uh
um I don't think that I have but I've
definitely wondered that I've watched a
lot more matches than I've played
um in my case when I played the match
during the break I just had to like try
to remember what I was planning to do
like oh my gosh you were going to try
you know the appearance defense won game
and see what they did you know
um so I need to just focus on on sort of
getting my own brain together
uh during the breaks but I've always
wondered if for these players like do
they look up one critical line
um
yeah for me I always actually I wouldn't
say always but usually there's an
opening that keeps getting played and
you want to know what's going on in that
position so I take like two minutes uh
to check it with the engine but I also
know some players just like to stay
fresh use this break as a real break and
you know take take a second walk around
get some rest so here we see uh grishek
trying a new move in the line that
they've played two games in a row the
the first opening line to give ding
you know draws with black
um is this line here and now grishook's
trying Bishop D2 instead of Bishop E3
yeah this is a unique approach I
remember Fabiano was the first one to
put it on the map the famous candidates
game against Levon aronian
so
yeah usually the idea is to delay the
movement of either Knights through C3 in
this case he did end up playing C3 and
now it's gonna probably develop in a
more standard fashion
and so now you have to be like an ultra
super GM to understand what white gained
by playing Bishop D2 to E3
yeah at least my caliber would not
understand it okay
it's like
somehow he tricked black into playing B5
C5 and D5 Maybe
but are you really tricking me no I
don't I don't know it doesn't look like
to me it doesn't look like a trick I use
that that that word with a lot of humor
I
seems like like if I were black I would
want to play all those moves
yeah he got a lot of space everywhere
now he can gain even more space with the
move like F5 I'm not sure how you feel
about this
it's it's the move I've got my eye on
um and he does play it
so now I guess if Knight E2 you just go
I don't know Queen F6 or Bishop back to
D6
also possible
I guess you're not really that concerned
with this lawn diagonal
for the moment the Knight on A5 is
covering
B3
yeah actually B4 is a really important
question if
we played Bishop diesel oh
um well worst case scenario I can take I
guess your point is that after Bishop
before white will take on E5 but I think
I can go Knight C6 in that position
right you're gonna take once and then
put the Knight on a great Square
yeah I think I would take and go Knight
C6 I'll give you a check but it's only
one check maybe khader H7 is fine
yeah not enough to build a an attack on
so get Queen E2
yeah we have six they're fighting over
that pawn if Rook to E1 we'll just get
Knight C6 should be fine
should be
but white does build this legendary
triple stack maybe D4 is
is an idea
[Music]
um just trying to open up lines
ah D4 is sure messy I mean it's
feels like a pawn sack
he's gonna try something else this
should be three checks does he simply
want to plant the bishop on D5
then train on C6 and finally win that E5
Pawn I mean right you could accuse white
of being obsessed with the pawn on E5
it is Black's main weakness in the
position so I understand
this approach
I'm
you have always got to be worried about
some F4 ideas trapping The Rook all
right it goes Bishop B6
uh he was truly worried about Bishop D5
now I'm wondering in this case can I
take and go D4 this is a good version
for me
now that the Rook on E8 is not defended
it seems like a much better version
black will probably instead of taking
the pawn sack be looking at some version
of pushing past
with E4
again a very conservative approach by
Grisha this is like the sort of thing I
would expect if you're leading in the
match
but I'm still way like Queen B3 and
black Intrigue yeah Rook A2 yeah I
understand it's very solid but I would
be looking for chances at some point
okay Queen D5 can you strike with C4
it's an idea I guess
okay he looks at the F5 pawn and ding
immediately defends it like we're not
we're not giving you any looks here
yes
whoa and we're just getting word that
fobby's in the chat hello
uh he's promising that the match is
going to become close
I mean I had the same impression but I
I'm also can I ask Fabi what does he
think about grishek's like overall plain
style seems so conservative to me
I feel like at some point he needs to
find
you know like a change in Dynamics
after six moves of posturing around
Queen B3 Queen B3 does get played I
didn't really see where else he was
going with this
and Rook A2 gets played
I just don't like this
transformation by by grishek and he
feels like he's flailing around like he
moved this Knight already five times
yeah you may again tell me I'm giving
too much credit but I again I feel like
like how do you beat a player like ding
in this position here when black is so
smooth and low on weaknesses
you just don't
okay this is so this time yeah
next Rook to A2 centralize the king I
mean to me the question actually is if
ding is going to try and turn it around
and torture white because
I would think he's a little bit better
Space is really matters in night end
games doesn't it
yeah it's getting a little bit squeezed
they are getting very squeezed here
Knight D5 just a really safe position
for ding playing with two results at
some point C4 could be a move
yeah somewhere when the knights on C2 uh
sorry on C1 when you like when it's on a
bad spot you could sort of trade one
night and play C4 against the remaining
one for sure yeah but for the moment
he's just gonna continue restricting
whites Knights probably Rook back to A2
makes a lot of sense
but he was there and he found nothing so
he he looks around
at some point if he wants to progress he
has to throw in a c4 but maybe he
doesn't want to take a risk maybe like
why risk it with on the clock
yeah
practical decision there just maintain
the two-point lead
move on to the next game
by the way it wasn't hold on a second
can you refresh my memory was ding
starting with C4 and Knight F3 when they
were getting that symmetrical English
you know the first couple moves were
going so fast I'm not even right exactly
yeah I'm not but I would think one C4 I
thought one C4 yeah so I'm surprised
that he's giving Grisha the extra option
of playing
um ready with meta3d5 yeah given how
well those those that whole string of uh
English games he won like four English
games in a row in that symmetrical line
exclusively
so maybe he's saving it for the bullet I
don't know
all right so there's this queen B3 line
Queen B6 I think goes D3 white likes to
trade uh Play Bishop E3
in these lines
takes first ah now he switches to this
plan with Knight C3 playing for E4
foreign
and
mm-hmm
oh yeah black can't really play D4
because of Knight A4
right yeah that was not an option uh
before castling
so yeah I would go Knight H4 here yep
ah but Bishop E3 is a nice Tempo too
that cannot hurt yeah
and this is this looks very good for
white
um
after after just Knight H4 not sure why
I needed H3
but okay it helps
so
black needs to find something
constructive to do because white has a
straightforward idea a straightforward
idea of Knight H4 F4
and just blast you on the king's side
so I don't know can black try and Target
D3
yeah or try to you know use the D4
threat to destabilize White's pieces
wondering about 95 here yep 95 65. we're
Knights C5
um
okay he goes 95 takes
now what is this position like if D4
Knight C4 E5 Maybe
you allow 93 at the expense black has to
worry about at file pressure
is there any option to keep the bishop
here
all right we got E5
at H7
now E6 would be an option but I'm not
sure
like E6 could be F5 so it goes H4
so that's keeping the Knight out keeping
the night at Bay yeah keeping the night
at Bay maybe some H5 ideas later and of
course H5 is going to be the big idea
okay this is good cutting yeah cutting
off the square nice that would not have
been available if the night we're moving
through G5 instead of f8 and it feels
like black never wants to take on E3
because F7 would be far too soft but C5
weakens the D5 Pawn
Alsina sense here something that I think
is really important that Ding is very
familiar strategically with what he does
or doesn't like with the evaluations of
the different trades
um like he doesn't have to think too
hard about do I want to take on C5 what
happens if they take on E3 do I ever
want to play Bishop C1
and that helps a lot in Blitz right just
to have some idea of
yeah that is a very good evaluations
and I would simply draw back with my
Bishop here because D5 is so loose now
that C5 has been played you know
Bishop G2 would threaten Knight D5 and I
don't even know if you have a convenient
way to stop that
is there anything else he could be
considering here because he's thinking a
while so dc593 looks like trash because
Bishop C1 an option yeah I considered it
but I don't like allowing CD4 and maybe
you take on E5 next so 92 okay wants to
keep the bishop here
he was ready for that too okay
but this is starting to get unclear
Knight D5 what's the plan oh 95.
I missed that
um I guess you would have to take a rook
gate there
but I think that was a tactic yeah all
right because D1 would be hanging right
there were some Rook 88 and get
everybody out yeah
okay so he simply defends Black's sort
of threat of Bishop takes H4 which is
not like a super powerful threat
okay but definitely useful also he
protects on G3 on in the case of Knight
takes E3
okay Rook C and E6 played instantly well
okay
40 seconds each what is going on here
this Knight takes D5 should be noted
like F5 Knight D5 would all of a sudden
be crushing
so and if you take only six
maybe you can get away with that I'm not
sure
how about throwing in
CD4 CD4 I'm wearing the black yeah but
then white throws an EF yeah
I mean it still looks playable he does
he does do it
so King F7
and there's a discovery here by the way
I just realized seconds and he leaves
them why did he go kh7 there he could
have taken and gone 93 anyway
there was no there was no reason to to
let this Pawn stay alive
yeah all right he's gonna take that one
watch out for agentsy move attacks every
single piece
wins the next but with the F7 Pawn
this should be six
okay Knight H3 to keep the Knight
nice move here wait Queen D4 or queen H4
oh my goodness there's check mating
ideas oh my
oh that's nasty Queen E4 check there's
mate there's mate here you take Knight
G5 and 96 that's it
I mean it's G5 then there's G5 oh this
is even better G5 this way there's
Knight of four goodness yeah Rook H1
nasty finish from ding boom
but yeah there was no reason to to not
take on F7 there
yeah sort of maybe a piece of it could
have been the time trouble there for
sure it was the time dribble yeah he saw
ghosts at the last second and this is
the biggest margin that's been three
point lead I feel like this game is
absolutely vital for Good Ship to bounce
back in get back into the match somewhat
all right grishek is gonna try his own
hand at this English
that was sort of our first Checkmate
right I mean we had One Catalan where
ding played G4 G5 and chased the king
out into the center and won the queen
with Rook D3
um thanks to some Checkmate threats
um this kind of like our first just
absolutely King just getting
finished with a little tactic yeah ding
has been super sharp in those types of
positions where he gets an attack he's
been seeing the killer blows we saw
another game where he sacked the queen
and another one where he also had like a
knight takes B7 shot so when he's had an
opportunity he's always seen it yeah the
Knight looks vulnerable to this G5 move
but G5 D4 would always be sort of like
right yeah like a Counter-Strike there
opening up your Bishop this is Theory I
believe I don't remember how it goes
whoa but I know this is Theory it's like
Castle's G5
it looks a little primitive by black
doesn't it
if you don't know what you're doing you
just lose yeah
okay D4 and F3 I guess
um
what is going on here exactly
I wish fobby were still here I know that
he plays this for white
so he could sort of instruct us uh he
says I think brishic played this in 2019
with black okay
I remember Fabi also had a game against
yesapenko maybe maybe a slightly
different line from wike
aha H3
yeah this is super chaotic
so if Knight H6 then you aren't even
threatening to take the Knight anymore
because the Knight on H6 would be all
right Benjamin Buck also in our chat
welcome he's confirming yeah Anton
Grisha the last round of Isle of Man
yeah I do know I was at the tournament
as well I do vaguely remember that
this position has like a tense mix of
Black's play being primitive and not
developing their pieces and White's King
being in danger so like I don't know if
I'm white if I should be scoffing at
what Black's doing or if I should be
quaking
I would have actually gone Bishop before
there by the way instead just to develop
my Bishop with Tempo but this one I
still don't know
who is better and why
I did not expect G5 I was not on my list
foreign
Rook G8
and
you're left with this question of
I mean how is Bishop on G2 ever going to
get in the game
oh there could be some Bishop takes E4
tactic but not not really because he
would open the Dag
so I'm thinking
just Bishop E7 here
Black's pieces are suddenly starting to
come together too
foreign
just leave the king in the center for
now huh yeah there's another approach
that he's considering I think taking a
knight A5
makes a lot of sense
two but you do weaken the dark squares
um
very hard to judge
yeah I suppose if you did that you'd
give white a chance for one moment to
bring the bishop tap sticks if they
prefer that
[Music]
um
but again again he's thinking for too
long like
yeah I just go with go with your gut
there Bishop B7 and Rook G8
oh I mixed up the colors for some reason
I thought ding was white I'm too used to
him playing the English him playing the
English I forgot yeah
griswick is white in this game okay
um
now if Queen D2 Rook Jade I don't see
exactly what to do
I'm trying to set up this bishop V4
somehow but it never works
okay Queen B3
Knight D4 among other possibilities
now hang on can I take on e4 now no
there's Knight D4
okay maybe I start with Rook D1 then
with that Rook
well I can tell you I wanted to play
Rook C1 when he played Queen B3 so
he must have some idea to play on the C
file I think he might have had Bishop
before D5 in that Split Second but I'm
not sure it's it was so hard to
calculate he plays Rook C1 Rook G8
connected Force so Bishop G5 met with
Knight C5
and Knight A5
would just force him to see too
yes and no clear follow-up maybe you go
B6
whoa Rook take G5
laughs
straight up violence
I would never have considered that
in a million years so what if I take a
knight C5
guess you go Queen this queen
no but where do you even put the queen
there
um
maybe I mean I guess you're saying that
like D4 and stuff is saying all right
we're gonna see the line so Knight B7
you take on C1 but then I take on d8
okay plays E3 but that now now that
allows Bishop C8 black consolidates
consolidates oh here comes the material
disadvantage
the Y Queen is tied down to the epon so
you can't play Rook H6 without having to
worry Rook G6 he goes network of two oh
this is razor sharp do you go Queen D6
here F6
please have six Queen D5 Bishop E3 and
Knight E4
protecting G3 there's also Knight D6 are
unsafe Kings I have no idea what's going
on yet PH2 always met with Rook H6
rookie one played the two endangered
Kings just grab the pawn yep
um all right Queen E5 offering the queen
trade black is up a pawn at the end of
the day black is up a pawn here
both around five seconds Gotta Move
okay this Rook is boxed out from the
game though
so you go Knight D6 Bishop V6 back you
have to control F5
can you get away with this check
we have seven eyes got rooked before
yeah this is good for Dean
but now he loses B7 okay takes an ID3
two results game but should be a draw
most likely
Knight D1 no but this doesn't let's just
lose
yeah it should be a draw here
Bishop A6
wow
but that was super wild before they
traded Queens
so I see about have 8 45 on the match
clock maybe yeah that's time for two
games should be another two games yeah
and exhaustion material that was that
was an epic battle I I'm impressed with
that one really exciting stuff and
grishek I feel he also senses that he
needs to start mixing things up really
that's right
putting putting fire on the board yeah I
think he agreed with you that that E4
line he wasn't it was just too too
technical uh ding has sort of found what
he wanted to do with that line
I thought he says why draw mate was
still possible yeah that's true that's
true actually
that should not have been an auto draw
yeah I feel like normally I flag in
those positions on chess.com and then it
and then it like gives the point to my
opponent so it's like well they you
could have put your king in the corner
and trapped it with your own piece
so we're already seeing some uh opening
adjustments from British this is a very
ambitious line I think fobby was the
first top player to sort of
uh reinvigorate this in a sense this
like E5 D6 Bishop V7 F5 approach and a
lot of players started copying him
um but I'm not sure I like
this specific position
King H1
my eye was on rookie one
yeah both moves I think will be played
right was this move necessary
uh
I think it's so it's always very useful
to to avoid
the checks here
um so now I either Bishop I probably go
Bishop V3 here
nice call
and now just we need to Rook a one and
for black long term it's super hard to
play with this hole on E6 also very
passive Bishop
black May at some point just force
matters with H6 because what else
tactic
oh Knight D5
that could be a thing however no but
your opponent hang is at the end so I
take on D5
um I guess I can show this
at the end of the day I've got dc6 and
queen yeah D6 so
not quite working mm-hmm
yeah that's the kind of line where the
king it's good that it's on H1 because
otherwise something like Queen E3 Knight
D3 and randomly black guy saves the game
yeah good point okay so rookie eight was
played
probably just Queen D2 can I please have
four which
I understand he opens the bishop but I'm
not sure I wanted to give black this E4
Square
well I guess the question is can black
immediately go to E4 or does black have
to defend C6 yeah I'm now realizing the
point if H6 there could be a bishop C5
and dc6 tactic
where leaving the Knight on G5 yeah yeah
so that's why Bishop D7
kind of was mandatory
okay and now we could get Rookie one all
right but the moment you give me time
I'm gonna go h694.
right I'm gonna play Bishop takes c596
against H6 that's a great concept great
concept yeah and sort of just good
opposite colored Bishops Quincy 2 a bit
left field for me Knight G4 the
follow-up right now Bishop you wanted to
move you want to play but then you black
can take twice on G5
so where do you go with this bishop can
you go to D2
um
I want to go to D4 and Sack the pawn but
I probably can't justify it yeah because
I'm worried it lets Black's pieces out
at the same time yeah and black can even
continue their attack
so Bishop D2 Bishop F6
uh 93 is lurking
as is Bishop D4 right Bishop D4 just
start getting really active
all of a sudden
grishek's pieces are starting to stream
in
yeah
can I
so if rookie won Bishop D4 maybe I go
have to go like Knight to one
something like that just to deal with
the threats
right
and then Rook C8 even I don't know it
feels like it feels like Black's really
got a lot of options here like you also
have Bishop D4 Queen F6 ideas
mm-hmm
swing the queen over
yeah he's thinking here can't think for
too long because I imagine the position
is going to get even more complicated as
that's right it has not yet reached
the worst it can get right Bishop D4
there is H3 though
oh there's a knight D3 move I'm just
noticing
yeah this could get wild live because
that could go with Queen B6
oh my gosh with some smothered mate
ideas
as well as you know he finds it in two
Pawn he finds it now there's an idf2 and
queen B6 wherever your Rook goes I'll go
Knight df2 Queen B6 I love your idea
there oh tough moment for ding
it's not 20 seconds on the clock it's
not even easy to avoid some other
checkmate
Knight F2 and queen B6
go go go go go go
this is where this is where Grisha
really yeah he plays it this is where he
has to step on the gas
hang on H2
excuse him one Knight D3 there's got to
be something I gotta get out of here I
just gotta get out how is this only
minus one looks totally winning
what is this if if it's only minus one
that's great instincts from ding to just
run his King out well I think there was
Knight D3 check instead that looked more
brutal now
foreign
played BC
oh is there Knight B5
oh my God number 95 Queen C5 still
Queen C5
just coolly drop it back
Queen C5 why is he thinking Queen C5
what's going on here all right now he's
down
why is he thinking Queen C5 in the
bullet portion too way too long there
okay Rook C8 just keep the pressure on
wait did he blunder a fork Knight A6 oh
my gosh
all right Queen D4 96 take it
but he can now the king's open from both
angles
okay can you take on A2
still should be good it's gonna come in
oh he wins on time yeah way too much
that was just
wow Madness
all right so we have time for one more
game in this section but Jeffrey that
was the first game that black has won
this match oh my God that's crazy yeah
15 games into the match wow it's like
the first time that there that black got
that kind of dynamic play almost the
first time black threatened to win a
game but this is what I like to see from
grishek where that's the first game that
he sort of just mixed it up even at the
cost of his own position right
objectively we knew white was better at
the opening but you're initiating
complications and that's what he he
wants to do uh in considering the math
situation so let's see if he keeps doing
that
okay
this is a line that grishek has played
before I think is it Bishop C3 BC
certainly going to be Bishop C3 because
Black's got B7 and D5 sort of hanging
yeah I'm trying to remember how this
line goes it's like an end game I think
uh Queen B4 or no no now it's slightly
different okay
um
so yeah white has two Bishops but a
weakness on C3 that black and black
tries to exploit
so maybe go B6 here or he's going G5
and 90.
so there goes the bishop pair problem
yeah he can take on G3 whenever he wants
I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure he will
though
right
foreign
sex
so I mean what does white I want to
achieve in these positions
C4 and trade the pawn Fabi said this is
aronian Robson from US championships aha
yeah I vaguely remember that game where
maybe Levon was better at first than Ray
got chances later in the end game
logical play from White got rid of the
weak C Pawn you opened the Bishops Rook
D1 is coming
now your whole Advantage I think is to
create an attack against Black's King
and black immediately tries to trade
Queens
right it makes sense if you felt Danger
on the king side but this should be
slightly worse right I could take on B6
there no it goes A3
can I
maybe I just take everything like take
on G3 take on b494 that's one option
um
not easy to find other ideas that you
can play you can play an improving move
I guess Rook FDA
your option sounds logical to me
let's trade everything 94 play A6
and
it doesn't feel like Black's worse to me
yeah we'll see what he wants to do
um
NH3 feels like the simple one
all right it's down a minute now
and time has expired in the three minute
portion of course
yeah it does offer Rook FDA
um
now I guess Grisha can also play this
slow either with Rook fc1 I don't know
if you want to exchange or just keep the
tension there
I I think he's just gonna go Rook fc1
there must be some concern that if he
takes on B6 he can never access the B1
Square because of Bishop G6 and so he
can like make anything out of it
yeah so he's gonna I guess
he's gonna put his Rooks on C1 and D1
instead
which is going to lead to a lot of
trains
yeah I'm not sure what to make this I'm
worried about the night starting to to
hop I mean Knight d2's the big threat I
was surprised he played Rook a and not
Rook f
right yeah he has to
worry about that with the F1 I guess so
now it's rook fd1 in that case but then
Knight B2 yeah
that's a real horror
um
yikes
does he have Knight E6 here to try and
unravel his problems
96 The Rook I could just move the Rook
whoa that would be
that would be something
but yeah maybe Rook D7 in that case yeah
just just a simple move
um
uh how do you actually deal with this
Knight D2 threat is there
Bishop
maybe it should be three but then Knight
C3
poof
tricky tricky position for Grisha and
now and now Chris shook is down on time
he was up a minute before this moment
I have no idea what to what to do
running low okay one maybe yikes okay
but Bishop V2 now I'm guessing just
Knight AC3 ah he wants to swing the
bishop to G4 perhaps
it was a three this allows Knight D2
once again
Maybe
oh there's so many attackers B7 yeah but
there might be ropes cover each other
Rook D4 in that position maybe not
this is
oh there's so many tactics in this
position
I would say that should work out for
white if we emerge into that obstacle
into that position if you if you keep
the G3 bishop and get Bishop B7
yeah now he can either take another
moment to trade yeah this should be
seven
and I guess just Rook C7 there
because there are Rook d492 ideas white
has to watch out
right does he have Rook D4 Bishop C8
Rook C4 right here oh Rook C4 oh my gosh
well
well I can take on C3 there so it's not
losing well 92 check does this work hang
on how does this work I think he had to
follow up with your Rook C4 move King F2
King H2 it doesn't matter everything is
so ding's content with sacrificing The
Exchange
um
oh man
so now we gotta watch out for Bishop E4
for white oh great move great move
exchanging the Bishops
yeah the a pawn will be gone eventually
anyway
only having three seconds on the clock
he gives him like the huge respect
well I think it was over there with Rook
H7 but clutch much needed win for
grishek
he gets within one
and we're heading into the bullet
section
right and uh we're gonna take a short
break everybody we'll be back with with
bullet in just a minute uh drop your
predictions in chat I think an obvious
prediction is that this match has gotten
very close as uh Bobby told us when he
popped in Midway through the three
minutes
foreign
[Music]
there either Rook C7 a7's falling uh it
is E4 he pushes the pawn this is getting
a little messy takes a knight F1
. you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds when
that move was played
I was missing King C2 and run the king
king 93. takes it
takes it right here
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3 oh my God and
instead he played here oh my God A7 wins
for white oh my gosh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
is brewing you're never going to beat
hikarados on game not in these positions
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
imagine down to five seconds gonna move
oh we missed it oh yeah
for some this is familiar ground I've
never seen Madness play a move like that
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess
that is
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
and welcome back everybody to the 2022
speed chess championships here on
chess.com
uh we see Alexander grashook getting
ready for the bullet section and uh
Jeffrey how's how's this match going
oh man it's been
huge excitement all around I think
especially these last two games by
Grisha super crucial to narrow the Gap
to one heading into bullet also I'd
argue that momentum is now on his side
so we'll see if ding can uh sort of
re-strengthen his his control over this
match because he might be a bit rattled
after those last two games
and what would be worth more to you at
this point in the match momentum or a
one-point lead what would you rather
have going into the one minute
uh that's a very difficult question I
think it it depends a lot on the players
some players like I'd say nepo when they
get momentum they can be unstoppable so
against him I would say momentum but a
player like ding I don't think ding ever
tilts so I would still in this scenario
I would still say that he should be a
favorite even if grishek has momentum on
his side
okay so if you have the choice here you
would still pick the point uh I would I
would and for shook you would rather
have lost the last game of the three
minute portion but behead of but be
ahead of point then come into the bullet
on a streak
yeah I would say with both players
involved they seem
like they're veterans they don't
they don't have these wild swings that
maybe some of the younger players like
myself would go through like I can lose
five bullet games in a row no problem
but these two guys are juggernauts they
know how to control emotions and I
expect again like just back and forth
action here okay so then again in terms
of what to expect in the bullet you're
not expecting like five game streaks
you're expecting some some give and take
totally yeah
cool
well let's hope so that's always
exciting that's always exciting I do
think the match has gotten pretty close
to uh 50 50 rather than you know the 60
40.
uh estimates and predictions that we had
in advance
yeah and
I'm sorry I'm trying to understand what
is going on with these nights here in
these two nights yeah will one of them
die
or will they both hop to happiness
there's or there was already a move like
F6 strapping the Knight but maybe there
was some Queen takes E4
um
however if white is going to get in D3
and save those Knights should be a
slight Edge
well that's a lot of gymnastics for a
very slight Edge I'm gonna say like the
risk to reward was like lots of risk and
a nice little reward
although maybe the reward could start
growing like if you start activating the
pieces here
maybe B for Bishop B2
I don't know could start looking up for
white
yeah he couldn't resist the look at the
Queen Bishop F4 boom and now he's ready
aha Bishop D5 I guess CD
and you trade Queens there
so
six six
uh-huh so Queen's 497 King h8
not sure I didn't have to play Queen C4
by the way I think they could have
played a move like Queen C5 and just
Queen C5 but I take on E7 there yeah
yeah there was I saw the engine also was
giving something but okay uh there seems
to be a problem because there's only one
legal move but he's thinking promise
Black's clock is down now
I
that's rough oh
and he's like what am I supposed to do
kind of
signal there will the second game start
yeah he's back I don't think
yeah I was just
just a brief moment he lost connection
very unfortunate way to lose a point
ouch
now you go from straight from momentum
to tilt when your connection does that
to you yeah it is that is true he needs
to find a way to maintain his composure
that was clearly
oh I mean terrible luck at the worst
time
but if he it's still a two-point Gap
just got to play good chess right now
for sure
probably G6 next
preparing for sure kid white just throw
the Knight on F5 no chooses not to
94 rookie 4 covers the night
uh-huh and G6 there's Knight G6 so this
move yeah Knight H4 prevented
I guess you'll just take on E6 here
you've got to watch out for B3 ideas
from black so that's why I take
yeah but then after black plays fe6 you
spent all this time bringing the Knight
to F5 it's hard to accept
true yeah your knight would instantly be
removed
from its pedestal yeah yeah everybody
hates to work for nothing and he comes
up with some other move I don't even
know what that move was
yeah he's playing Rook of one maybe with
the idea of f4
okay
so as black you have a lot of pawn moves
to consider C4 D5 or B3 he goes for C4
yeah B3 wasn't yet good right because of
Bishop A5 right Bishop A5 and Bishop B3
maybe not so clear so I like the C4 move
B3 would be a huge threat which grishok
ignores
I love when people ignore threats
it does make for some excitement and
after D4 by the way this bishop B1 which
looks completely out of the game
would suddenly be on a juicy diagonal
right and uh White's controlling D4 so
black doesn't even have the option right
in on D4
although he's gonna try
can he go id4 strong
oh Queen B6 is also very strong yeah
that's a nice there
and there might be some tactics here
connected with D5 he goes for it f e
foreign
so fe5 D4 I guess and you take the
bishop five seconds for grishook can you
find a way out of this bishop B1 Knight
D4 Maybe
or EF
lots of stuff hanging opening up the
board I think you go
Abba how do you do this because F6 is
hanging out do you go Knight D7
whoa he finds Knight C2 takes
yikes
sick and teach hang on but When the
Smoke Clears I think grishek should be
happy about this he's going to win C2
please
Knight F5 sacking a piece oh my
God
huge still Sharp
is there some tactic here uh very very
close but I didn't see it
okay both sides are just making moves
here oh H4 Rook F7
blacks
what is going on okay text KH but
there's nothing
somehow there is nothing there
you know they're just going to draw here
at King G8
no ding goes first there's three pawns
he comes out
but black has great control black has
great control of the dark swords here
and he can go after White's King
lots of check he's probably going to be
able to win B2 she does Queen H7 that's
going to cost the age Pawn
four seconds three seconds why do you
give it with check
okay yeah now he's just gotta move he's
got to move wait there was Queen G7
there it's like uh
point back on time
uh it's not over there's still a lot of
checks but you escape you escape through
H4 G5
well
oh but Queen A5 I didn't even see that
yeah that was a little surprise
still some work to do
all right Queen G6 Queen G6 he's got him
and then I think you can take in G5 yeah
with check huge win get it back to one
but yeah that could have gone either way
yeah big bing had the extra Bishop could
have repeated
brought out and then he just like hit
that one move where he where he sort of
like in actual seconds didn't quite flag
but
the board just got down to a second
all right so we see another Catalan
so group shook had one-on-one bad game
with the Catalan that I
did yes
okay now this side is very dangerous in
bullet like there can be some Knights
594 if being once but okay he goes for
something else
looks like grishook wants him to play
Knight G5
yeah I it's hard to say which side that
would favor in a bullet game
um but this one
Queen B6
uh
hold on a second okay 93 very logical
kick the bishop that's nice you want the
bishop to move so you have Bishop e3
coming with tempo nice retreating move
there
yeah that takes all the stuff's position
he's gonna slightly more
yep
that's suffering ding you three seconds
well now a few more yeah nothing ding
can take some time here to figure out
how he wants to pose problems
yeah
um
but then there's 95.
yeah rookie one Bishop D5 so I like this
decision just to get rid of the Knight
now you can use one of these files to
invade
all right so he takes like a really
small Edge into the so-called Fischer
endgame of rook and Bishop versus rook
and Knight
and it looks promising after A5 I think
you have to defend it passively with
Rook B8
because Rook C2 yeah I thought king of
three here
and now how do you
I guess you can try B4 but wait b55
looked really scary to me when uh yes
and now E4
ah there's 97 hang on
nice idea by grishek keeping the pawn
alive momentarily
oh yeah and Knight C6 is a huge threat
to the B2 Pawn
yes so how do we
how do we keep anything here maybe oh
Rook C5 Knight C6 anyway because you
have the fork
and ding doesn't see how to deal with it
so there are gonna make a draw of this
game yep
now
if hikara was white he might play like
100 moves in this ending but I expect
ding will just make the draw here yeah
these players have been
like resigning when they're when they're
losing agreeing to draws when they're
drawing I think they it's too early yeah
it's too early to do this kind of
stalling yeah
yeah I think also that the impression I
get is they both care about what the
position is on the board
totally you know what I mean like it's
like
to them it's still it's still chess even
though it's played super fast
whereas for some people it's a totally
different game right it's like
you know what I mean it's like for some
people like if they could flag you with
one Pawn against two queens two Rooks
and two knights like that's really
awesome to them and that's that's the
game that they're playing towards but I
feel like these players would just sort
of resign and once they're down to
Queens you know they the the chance of
getting that draw is not something that
or or flag is not something that
interests them at that point
you're absolutely right on that yeah
both I'm sure have tremendous respect
for each other respect for uh the
objectivity of the game and to your
point there won't be any flags with down
two queens Rooks and knights with the
increment though
yeah
but I mean there are some people who do
play for that even with a one second
increment it's not a lot you know you
can you can Mouse slip or with the
connections right I mean if they wanted
to say Never Say Die they each have
reason to like maybe the other guy's
connection is going to go out and we
haven't seen that
F4 F5 I like this for I like it for ding
trying to play along the light squares
yeah me too
can you take on F4 oh yeah Knight H4
there's an H4 and I think there's got to
be some tactics coming with Bishop F6
yeah I thought white missed their chance
earlier to trade one Pawn on the queen
side a takes B6 Knight C4 and and sort
of find some Maneuvers for the pieces
but now as the word blows up I would be
very happy to have black
oh me too and how do you even deal with
this
I mean you can read your book and on
Bishop C3 play Queen H4 oh wow and he's
gonna try that
I guess it was
it's not losing immediately foreign
exchange he doesn't even take the
exchange it's too much yeah it's just
too much I think you just simplify it
now
yeah now we can just take it off and uh
very convincing win there by ding with
the black pieces it's back up to two
yeah
for those just joining us in bullied was
as big as three points for dingley Ren
and he was sort of methodically
increasing his advantage in the five
minute and three minute portion until
Chris shook Uncorked the only black win
the first black win the only black win
of of the blitz section and won two
games in a row and brought us into an
extremely close bullet match here
and that game just now might have been
ding's first win with black that has to
be confirmed but we have seen like an
absolute whitewash white totally
dominating this match thus far yeah
um
big leads on the clock and and nice
positions at the same time
so I've played this for white I think E3
is a very typical move that the the
engine suggests
um but he's gonna go Bishop D6 right
away sometimes even to sacrifice the
pawn but you open the C fell you get
some squares
at some point
like even Queen B8 could scoop it up
it goes Knight B6 all right so this is
what I'm saying he's gonna try and just
sack the pawn
but in exchange he gets the pawn on E5
maybe Knight on H5
is boxed out and the other night will
jump on C5
yeah Rook C1
I'm worried about F6
this is the one thing that
black can try
like A4
mm-hmm looks like that Way's next move
anyway
yeah I like this for ding I think if you
can just go B3 put the other net on D3
and F4
it looks really nice
yeah he's got amplements
oh he's gonna play 95 and Bishop F3
kill this Knight and then put that on F4
wow super technical
that's it that's a master quest
foreign
well this is also huge I mean you've got
Rook H6 you can go after the A3 Pawn
whenever you want also Rook C1 Knight D3
transfer the Knight
oh this looks lovely
Knight D3
yep
93 or Rook H1 both are very good
but this is
just a nightmare for Grisha and he might
get tortured here for another few
minutes so it's a game where you could
lose slowly
oh my gosh Total Domination it's a point
where it's better to just resign this
right because of you might want to
resign yeah you're spending match time
on a game that's just gone I mean
it's also it's getting to the point it's
getting to the point where I'd actually
rather resign than play like it's such a
sad position
yeah but okay ding taking his time here
I guess he's not sure if he wants to go
after the a pawn or not was there
anything wrong with Rook A7
I don't see anything wrong with that
yeah
but King G5 this is another way to crash
through
and he's gonna go at some point G4 G5
yeah he's trying to clean Jeep that's
saying that's clinical so passive
clinical way to finish
foreign
no checks here
oh my God that is sick
it wasn't quite the level of clean I
would want in my own clinic but uh it
was uh it was nonetheless the third
point the biggest lead we've had today
uh tied up
here
yeah most important was
was that he got the job done and for
grishek only 12 a bit more than 12
minutes I guess that's like five games
he probably has to win this one with
white
yeah girl spends a whole temp A3 to
avoid that big form of the uh the
semi-tourage you've been playing that
yourself
slightly
right it's very slightly better for
white with the space advantage
Pawn on e4 okay
um
now I think I want to see in Kettle but
it's difficult maybe I gotta go Bishop
D7 instead
yeah I can't imagine how you're gonna be
sex is black did he really just spend 30
seconds on a moving bullet
how should I develop
oh what I think he's only got two bars
now maybe it's
a connection issue I'm not sure I think
it was just connection Dang if so I
think it is yeah wow oh it really is
um trying to see if his camera is is
freezing or not
but yeah he's down to two bars which is
not not a good sign
still a very dry position
it's getting squeezed here
but 95 that's a good move
now these Bishops do control all
Invasion squares on the D file
so it is hard to break through for white
and I tried one more heavy piece
yeah he's actually he might be able to
to get away with with this I mean
he's got everything protected
but one second per move I'm not sure how
long you can sustain that pace
Rook comes off the board he should be in
the clear
in which case he played this entire game
like from move 12 on off of like 10
seconds yes the whole middle game the
whole end game everything
four is a nice move
hard for either side to do anything now
oh there could be a queen C4 idea
Queen's four Queen F1 yeah yeah that's
what I was thinking okay
but he's just playing it this should be
is there any way white can try and press
like with F4 or something
maybe bishop D5
I think Bishops okay but now odds
yeah it's still probably not enough
but let's see let's see there could be
H4 G5
foreign
H4
um
so he's allowing G5 but still
okay wait but now G6 now there's
basically you always have to be ready
for that
is it still a fortress though wow oh he
was ready he was ready he can see the
whole thing
the whole shape yes
he saw it coming from a mile away and
his King's on a tight leash
it's still it's still a fortress somehow
unless you go King D3 Bishop E3 because
I think you need control of this
diagonal
yeah I saw the bar jump there for some
reason what is it oh really oh there was
Bishop V5 and F6 oh my gosh oh but there
was actually it was always on the e-file
did he step to the default for one move
he stepped it on you can't do that yeah
whether The Bishop's threatening H6 or
E5 it's the same the king needs to stay
on that two-step leash
mm-hmm
ding now has more time than he had at
move 10. foreign
C5 should be a draw
yes
yes this is a draw
King C7 and and now the king's just and
now
mind squares if either player steps up
to C4 or B6 the other player does the
same and then you
are on the Mind Square you have to step
away and lose
yeah clutch save by ding after losing
half of his starting time in the first
10 moves
and oh only seven minutes I think now
grishek has to win every single game has
to win out three games
and just gotta start with black and he
goes to the king's Indian and you know
that one really key game he won with
black it started in a in an English
but it had that King's Indian feel later
on with Knight D3 and queen B6 you're
right it did and he's trying to recreate
that
um
but here I think ding has a good version
he's going to quickly get
Queen said play C5 is a good move
what if I take on C6 what do you even
recapture with
I'm wondering like is there some
I guess snipey 3 and C5 you meet it with
D5
all right I mean this is an imbalanced
position so at least there are going to
be chances
yeah you have to be satisfied at this
point in the game I mean it could all go
wrong in one or two moves but at this
point you've got what you all you can
ask for all you can ask for is an
imbalance I feel
takes on D5 now if black
is able to stabilize in the center it's
a very good position
and I think you can because you always
have Knight C7 at your disposal maybe
just F6
yeah F6 it should be
mhm
just consolidate everything in the
center
maybe D4
and I like both more so you might want
F5 first ah F5 first makes a lot of
sense yeah
and can he start pushing these down the
board
now he could push them oh but he goes
for the king side inside of the center
wow he wants E4 F3 and mate yeah that
was a big surprise to me I thought he
would go D4 E4 and try and just Crush
sweep the white pieces out
um and then clean up the queen side
Pawns
but maybe there are a few good ways to
to go forward here and dig down to 10
seconds
Knight D4
very promising for grishek do you go F3
he's got 30 seconds that's a notable
Advantage as well here yeah oh Rook A3
cool as a ding
it covers the third rank
but there's so many threats for black
is there Bishop E5 or like Bishop G4
which one do you play
and as long as ding doesn't like
drop anything he puts that pressure on
your shook to find High difficulty level
moves with 20 seconds that can be really
hard
yeah and Grisha getting low on time too
he has so many options here
Rook C7
oh God what's going on this is total
chaos now yeah takes Knight D4 is there
E3
I think this is good nice shot oh oh but
they're efficiency three the queen is
guarding F2
uh oh goodness Rook F2
ding has no time but he sacks yeah oh
and after the dust settles oh
Queen
how reasonable is it though I've got
Rook C5 I don't know he's got zero
seconds yeah I think for a second I
thought he was just gonna play A7 or
something you know and according to the
engine it was it was winning for white
but like down a queen and and you're
back rank with two okay so so there were
there were chances there there were
chances yeah but you're not going to be
able to find the Right Moves with with
two seconds
so that might have just been A7
yeah but that's step one for grishek so
he's got one down he needs two more
forced us into a tie break
yeah all right I like this too so
another imbalance he wants to get an E4
black dragon Bishop A6
King H1 looks unnecessary here but who
knows
okay this black one C5 yes
oh yeah I would say almost any time
whites played F3 you could play C5 if
you want to whoa I think that was a
mouse lip I think he wanted to go Bishop
f8 because Rook Cafe doesn't make any
sense and he went back
so now slipped there well spotted
luckily not the worst Mouse slip I've
ever seen no all it cost him was two
doubled white Rooks on the C file
when you put it like that yeah no but
you're right it could have been like you
know he could have hung his queen or
something or a rook and there you go
yeah this does look so bad for him two
white Rooks on the C file no longer look
like a big deal now they've been traded
absolutely now G6 cutting the Square Off
this is going to be hard for grishek to
win
yeah the thing is he's only spent like
20 seconds on this game so far right so
well but ding has even more time somehow
yeah but if ding just agreed to a draw
instead of running down the match clock
here no you don't have one more game you
only have time for another game yeah
this is a must win and I think rishik
knows it okay
so I need to work something up
I would say h4h5 to weaken the light
squares I know I've suggested that a few
times I like that idea a lot yeah
I like that idea you probably keep
Queens
yeah Queen D1 or queen E2 yeah but Queen
D1 allows Queen B2
wait he takes
the problem with Queen takes Queen is it
allows black to take White's Queen
yeah like the end game is gonna be
much closest to a draw than anything
although you are keeping this Pawn at
Bay with Knight D3
yeah I mean it'd be even worse if black
were queening immediately
it's possible that white can run his
King over and try and collect this guy
uh he wants to trade the Knight when
it's on D3
okay that's true if you can collect the
pawn
oh no can you do Bishop B2 and otherwise
there's G5 oh my gosh this might be one
G5 this might be game over
oh my goodness for 95 and Sac right yeah
but you're never ever winning this game
seems unlikely but let's see he's going
for the a pawn
uh yeah Knight B7 is super safe
oh man it should be this should be the
end of the match that Bishop on C1 is
pretty well placed yeah white skin
White's King can never Venture yeah he
can just move back and forth he doesn't
even need to win this is black right
just King he doesn't King E6 King D6
but just to be safe I guess he might he
might try to win I'm not sure but I'm
safe where's that no no no no no this is
eight or something
grishek might not even get another game
I glanced at the clock he might not even
get another game yeah
okay black throws in H5 I thought at
this point black was just playing King
B4 to A3 or something just like trying
to
finish it right there
yeah it's all over
the match clock has expired huh
so ding has won no matter what happens
with this game but he also won this
match on the board this game he did yeah
he looks like he's putting up the
fishing touches
um
yeah he can win this as slowly as he
wants
there he goes goes for it although here
he is allowing some chances it doesn't
matter of course but
maybe there's some chances for white no
did you see that Bishop takes E3 Knight
C4 check prick
oh with the fork yeah that was cheeky
not defending his e-pawn but uh thing
didn't fall for it and I see through
check didn't seem like it was in time
yet
so this is gonna end in a draw I'm
guessing
King D4
yeah you you go 24 was really clean okay
uh key four was fine yeah but this also
yeah
yeah so it will end in a two point
margin but I feel like ding always had
it under control yeah but that first
game where where Sasha lost connection
that was that was a killer and we'll
certainly ask him about it if he joins
us yeah what a what a battle that was
that last game too I mean just
Epic from both of them through almost
100 moves
um
so uh what what do you think who by how
many points was the one minute decided
by one extra point for ding
correct yeah because uh he had a one
point Advantage going in
and he never relinquished it
so I think we can say that he was the
worthy winner but yeah that I mean to
lose a game by connection when you've
done you've worked so hard to pull
within one and that happens it's just
it's gutting
yeah and that was right when we said he
had the momentum right it was just like
the very first taste of bullet was just
horrible horrible taste
all right wow so another match in the
books same two-point margin as the first
one very similar score I think the other
one was 14 and a half twelve and a half
so just one
um less game I guess and uh we will have
ding joining us shortly
I think now we'll take our final break
of the day wait we're gonna we're oh
yeah we're not gonna have an interview
today we're just gonna um go over a
couple things we're gonna show you all
where the bracket stands now ding uh the
second uh qualifier or sorry the second
player to go through to the
quarterfinals um on the opposite side of
the bracket from Fabi
and uh he will next face the winner of
the house iron versus Anish giri
um we've got another match for you all
tomorrow as well for anybody who's
really pumped up and is like three hours
of Blitz show me more show me more
um there will be another match uh
tomorrow and that is going to be
starting around this time so it's going
to be later than today's match it's
gonna start around right wow five
minutes from now tomorrow Monday
um dings uh ding's opponent for the
world championship match
foreign against the world Blitz Champion
current reigning world Blitz Champion uh
Maxima France yeah nepo versus mvl in
the first round like this could easily
be the finals
um it shows how crazy strong this SEC
field really is and I'm so looking
forward to this Blockbuster tomorrow
holy cow
yeah there's so many good players now
it's hard to know like who's the best
and that's part of the fun of the SCC
you know a chance for us to find out
who's the best at at Blitz right now
um and uh you know and then in terms of
the chess season it goes straight from
the speech has championships into the
world Blitz championships so fun to fun
to see all the Blitz in uh November and
December
um so I want to you know extend my
appreciation and admiration to the two
uh contestants that we watched today and
also to you Jeffrey for uh explaining a
lot of things about Chess to me and uh
the others in chat
yeah hopefully most of it was
understandable
um I know that I could can talk really
fast and the variations can be complex
even for me I I confuse myself all the
time but yeah it was a pleasure to work
with you David you are one of the
pioneers of chess.com
um so yeah just an honor to be here with
you and thanks for for joining all right
uh and thanks also to all of you our
viewers without whom uh chess.com
probably wouldn't bother to put on this
this show
um I hope you've been well entertained
um as we were by uh dangly Wren and
Alexander grishook and uh you know take
care have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow for the next match
all right thanks everyone
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign